Hi, I'm Sean, and this is smartless. By the way, you're not just one at a time. OK, just start again. Just do it one more time. Go. Hi, my name is Will R. No, I'm so good at this. You can't do it.
嗨，我是肖恩，这是《SmartLess》。顺便说一下，你不能一次只说一个。好吧，重新开始。再来一次。开始。嗨，我叫威尔·R。不，我太擅长这个了。你做不到。
OK, I was going to do it. And also, that's my name. Syllables. OK, so, OK, I know. Oh, my god. No wonder they call this show smartless. There you go. Smart, less, smart, less, smart, less.
好吧，我本来要做的。而且，那是我的名字。音节。好吧，我知道了。天哪。难怪他们把这个节目叫《SmartLess》。就是这样。Smart, less, smart, less, smart, less。
Will, before you hopped on, Jason and I were talking about timeliness and being on time. I said, you know, sometimes I go to the doctor's office 15 minutes late on purpose so that I can cover the 15 minute wait I would have had to do had I been on time. Right. You do that? No, no, I don't.
威尔，在你加入之前，杰森和我正在谈论守时和准时的问题。我说，你知道，有时我故意迟到15分钟去医生办公室，这样我就能抵消如果我准时到达本需要等待的15分钟。对吧。你真的那样做吗？不，不，我没有。
Will doesn't go to the doctor. His religion doesn't allow him to. But Paul is here. Well, here we go. Great. Now we're going to get the letters. Here come the letters. Herbs, right?
威尔不去医生那里。他的宗教信仰不允许他去。但保罗在这里。好吧，我们开始吧。太棒了。现在我们要收到信件了。信件来了。草药，对吧？
You just do it with herbs and you talk to this. You talk to the planets. And I do my crystals, as you know. And crystals. Were you ever into crystals? You were totally into crystals. No, I was more of a coke guy. Crystal was just too extreme for me.
你只是用草药来做，然后和这个对话。你和行星对话。正如你所知，我用我的水晶。还有水晶。你曾经迷过水晶吗？你完全迷过水晶。不，我更喜欢可乐。水晶对我来说太极端了。
Guys, we're having a blast. We're having a blast. No, did you ever do you believe in that you ever had your fortune read, like with tarot cards? You ever done that, Sean? Oh, yeah. I think a long time ago. Wait, sorry, that was for Sean.
伙计们，我们玩得很开心。我们玩得很开心。不，你相信那个吗？你有没有找人算过命，比如用塔罗牌？你做过吗，肖恩？哦，是的。我想是很久以前了。等等，抱歉，那是对肖恩说的。
But Jason, go ahead. You there. Insert story. Well, listen, if you must know, I'm married to a wonderful woman. Let me just start with a qualifier. And I will say, I'm not allergic to this whole notion of astrology. And I don't let it guide what I do.
但杰森，你继续。你在那儿。插入故事。好吧，听着，如果你一定要知道，我娶了一位很棒的女士。让我先加个限定词。我会说，我不排斥占星术这个概念。但我不会让它引导我的行为。
But sometimes it's kind of a fun, helpful, confirmer, right? Potentially. You don't believe that, though, because it's all generally speaking. Well, I was very circumspect about the whole thing, as a caveman like me. I got circumspect, too, when I was born.
但有时它是一种有趣、有帮助的确认，对吧？有可能。不过你不相信，因为那都是泛泛而谈。嗯，作为一个像我这样的穴居人，我对整件事非常谨慎。我出生时也很谨慎。
Yeah. No, I had a great doctor. Just beautiful, beautiful work. But the woman that I was with, well, girl, that I was with for eight years before Amanda, I should say young lady. We were in our teens and 20s. You get a lot of pushback.
是的。不，我有一位很棒的医生。非常漂亮，非常漂亮的工作。但是我和她在一起的那个女人，嗯，女孩，在阿曼达之前我和她在一起八年，我应该说是年轻女士。我们在十几二十岁的时候。你会遇到很多阻力。
I've seen pushback for using different terms. I've seen specifically us. And I know that you don't mean any harm by it. I'm just trying to keep up. So she would see an astrologist and did so for the full eight years we were together. Now, often my name would come up in her thing. And this woman, and then I consequently went in there,
我见过因为使用不同术语而产生的阻力。我特别见过我们。我知道你并没有恶意。我只是在努力跟上。所以她会去看占星师，我们在一起的整整八年里她都这么做。现在，我的名字经常出现在她的事情里。然后我因此也去了那里，
because my girlfriend got me a session or two. This woman's record, as far as accuracy goes with forecasting the future and what to look out, was 95% for eight full years. Now, hang on, here's the weird part. When I started going out with Amanda, my current wife, which was only a few years after me and the young lady, she was seeing the same woman.
因为我女朋友给我安排了一两次咨询。就预测未来和需要注意的事项而言，这个女人的记录准确率是95%，持续了整整八年。现在，等等，奇怪的部分来了。当我开始和阿曼达，也就是我现在的妻子约会时，那是在我和那位年轻女士分开几年后，她也在看同一个女人。
And so I now have been with Amanda for 20 years, loved every minute of it. I'm still seeing this woman. That's what you said last Thursday. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. So now I've got 30 years of this woman's record. Still, 95% accurate. OK, but so of what?
所以我现在和阿曼达在一起20年了，享受着每一分钟。我还在看这个女人。你上周四就是这么说的。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。所以我现在有这个女人30年的记录。仍然是95%的准确率。好吧，但是是什么的95%？
It's 95% right of predicting the future. I'm saying to watch out for the middle of December, there's going to be a situation and there's some specifics to it that are indisputably non-vague. Like what, like your chicken salad is going to come and the chicken's going to be overcooked, stuff like that? Well, no, no, but close. Because don't you think if there's somebody out there
预测未来有95%是对的。我是说要注意12月中旬，会有一个情况，而且有一些不可否认的非模糊的具体细节。比如什么，比如你的鸡肉沙拉要来了，鸡肉会煮过头，诸如此类？嗯，不，不，但很接近。因为你不觉得如果外面有某个人
that's that correct all the time that we know about it? Like, why? Well, but that's why you know about astrology. I'm telling you. You think that they'd be richer, they'd be billionaires. By the way, every time I see one of those, I drive by, I always go, I knew that was going to be there. So I heard a male laugh from our surprise guest.
一直那么准确，我们应该知道吗？比如，为什么？嗯，但这就是为什么你知道占星术。我告诉你。你以为他们会更富有，他们会成为亿万富翁。顺便说一下，每次我看到其中一个，我开车经过时，我总是说，我知道那会在那里。所以我听到了我们惊喜嘉宾的男性笑声。
He loves slash hates my terrible jokes and has for a long time. Well, who doesn't? Because I know that he's addicted to terrible jokes himself, which is just such a delightful quality. Right at my alley. Our guest today, I didn't know this. He was born in Mississippi.
他喜欢/讨厌我糟糕的笑话，而且已经很久了。嗯，谁不喜欢呢？因为我知道他自己也沉迷于糟糕的笑话，这真是一种令人愉快的品质。正合我意。我们今天的嘉宾，我不知道这一点。他出生在密西西比州。
He was born in Mississippi. I've known him for a number of years. I did not know this. Grew up in New York state and he originally started out in show business as a musician. He was a drummer for many years and then he parlayed that. He started to perform in a lot more comedies and sketch comedies, et cetera, et cetera.
他出生在密西西比州。我认识他很多年了。我不知道这一点。他在纽约州长大，最初是作为一名音乐家进入演艺圈的。他做了很多年的鼓手，然后他利用了这一点。他开始表演更多的喜剧和短剧喜剧，等等，等等。
As soon as I name, I started listing his credits. You're going to know who he is. So it's a race to just getting it all out as much as I can. Well, go slow because I want to guess. Put it this way. One of my favorite stories that, and I do want to talk to him about this, is that he had a brother who lived in East Berlin and he used to tell me stories about going to visit him,
一旦我开始列出他的作品，你就会知道他是谁。所以这是一场尽可能快地把它说出来的比赛。嗯，慢点，因为我想猜猜。这样说吧。我最喜欢的故事之一，我确实想和他谈谈这个，是他有一个住在东柏林的兄弟，他过去常给我讲去探望他的故事，
going through Checkpoint Charlie to visit his brother, A, which is a very unique experience. This is not a young guest. He's about our age. Jim Neighbors. Is it Jim Neighbors? This is Jim Neighbors? It's not Jim Neighbors.
穿过查理检查站去探望他的兄弟，A，这是一种非常独特的经历。这不是一位年轻的嘉宾。他大约和我们同龄。吉姆·内伯斯。是吉姆·内伯斯吗？这是吉姆·内伯斯？不是吉姆·内伯斯。
Jim, reveal your camera. No, but do not reveal. He's been nominated for many Emmys for writing. He has, he's nominated for, he actually received a Grammy nomination for best comedy album. He was a Saturday Night Live cast member for 11 years. He's created a bunch of shows, one of which is one of the funniest shows in memory called Portlandia.
吉姆，露出你的摄像头。不，但不要露出来。他曾多次获得艾美奖编剧提名。他确实获得了格莱美最佳喜剧专辑提名。他是《周六夜现场》的演员，待了11年。他创作了一堆节目，其中一个是记忆中最有趣的节目之一，叫《波特兰迪亚》。
It's one of my favorite people of all time. It's Fred Armisen. Comedy royalty. Oh, there it is. He is our Fred. Oh, look, he's back in East Berlin. It looks like you showered. Did you shower today?
他是我有史以来最喜欢的人之一。是弗雷德·阿米森。喜剧界的皇室成员。哦，就在那儿。他是我们的弗雷德。哦，看，他又回到东柏林了。看起来你洗澡了。你今天洗澡了吗？
I actually, I just did, I just did take a shower. I'm in London right now. Oh, you are? Oh. Yeah. What are you doing there? So we're only allowed to take showers at night here. That's how they're doing lockdown.
我确实，我刚刚确实洗了个澡。我现在在伦敦。哦，你是吗？哦。是的。你在那儿做什么？所以我们这里只允许在晚上洗澡。这就是他们实施封锁的方式。
They're doing lockdown like with showers and like with water and stuff, so. No way. What a weird, and there's no science behind it. They just came up with that. They just wanted a rule of some kind. Right. They were like, let's just think up the rule.
他们像用水和类似的东西进行封锁，所以。不会吧。多奇怪啊，而且背后没有任何科学依据。他们只是想出了那个。他们只是想要某种规则。对。他们就像，让我们想出一个规则。
This is just a real all-star booking here, Will. Freddie. I just, Will, you've really done it. That's fantastic. Fred is one of my favorite people of all time. Likewise. You don't like him more than I do. You don't like him more than I do.
这真是一个全明星阵容，威尔。弗雷迪。我只是，威尔，你真的做到了。太棒了。弗雷德是我有史以来最喜欢的人之一。同样。你并不比我更喜欢他。你并不比我更喜欢他。
Fred, you are universally known, now you're very well known as a comedian, as a performer, and as a writer, but what people don't know is you're maybe the greatest joker of all time. Yes. This is true. I want to receive.
弗雷德，你现在是众所周知的喜剧演员、表演者和编剧，但人们不知道的是，你可能是史上最伟大的开玩笑者。是的。这是真的。我想收到。
People who know Fred share stories of text they receive from Fred at various times. I've read your texts out loud. I have not, and I have not received any. Jason, we just haven't, we haven't kept in touch like that. Oh, come on. Well, first of all, you're all my favorite people. I love this podcast.
认识弗雷德的人分享过他们在不同时间收到弗雷德短信的故事。我大声读过你的短信。我没有，而且我没有收到任何短信。杰森，我们只是，我们没有那样保持联系。哦，得了吧。好吧，首先，你们都是我最喜欢的人。我喜欢这个播客。
I really do. I love you guys. I've worked with all of you. Are you saying goodbye right now? I think I've worked with- Are you saying goodbye? Yeah. We just started.
我真的喜欢。我爱你们。我和你们所有人都合作过。你现在是在告别吗？我想我和——你是在告别吗？是的。我们才刚刚开始。
No, because it's so late here. It's so late. Well, it's so great to have you. No, but I've worked with all you guys. Yeah. Isn't it crazy? Is this past your bedtime late? Or no, is it almost bedtime?
不，因为这里太晚了。太晚了。好吧，很高兴有你。不，但我确实和你们所有人都合作过。是的。这不疯狂吗？这过了你的睡觉时间了吗？或者不，快到睡觉时间了吗？
It is. And what are you doing there? It's nine o'clock at night. I'm shooting a show here. You know Matt Berry, the comedian Matt Berry? Of course, yeah. Yeah, so I'm doing that for like a week. No way.
是的。你在那儿做什么？现在是晚上九点。我在这里拍一个节目。你认识马特·贝里，那个喜剧演员马特·贝里吗？当然，是的。是的，所以我大概要在那儿待一周。不会吧。
Yeah. He's great. Matt Berry is a hilarious guy. He had a really funny show called Toast of London, but before that he was an incredible performer. He's been done amazing things for years. He's a profoundly funny guy. I've only met him once, I think, but yeah.
是的。他很棒。马特·贝里是一个搞笑的家伙。他有一个非常有趣的节目叫《伦敦烤面包》，但在此之前他是一位出色的表演者。他多年来做了令人惊叹的事情。他是一个非常有趣的人。我想我只见过他一次，但是的。
So that's fun. Are you, pardon my ignorance here, but if you don't know already, I'm an Indian. Just in general. Yeah, I'm usually in a cave. What is the status of Portlandia? Are you in the middle of that?
所以这很有趣。你，请原谅我的无知，但如果你还不知道，我是一个印度人。总的来说。是的，我通常待在洞穴里。《波特兰迪亚》的现状如何？你还在拍吗？
Are you done with that? No, no, we finished it like a couple of years ago. Okay, so you're... We did eight seasons. And that was it. We just... Yeah, that show was good. Thanks a lot.
你拍完了吗？不，不，我们几年前就结束了。好吧，所以你是……我们拍了八季。就是这样。我们只是……是的，那个节目很好。非常感谢。
Thank you. Now, do you want to do another one like that, or did you just like that was just too special, too great? I don't even want to try. Too special, I don't even want to try. That was like a perfect mix of getting to work with Kerry and getting to be in Portland and all that stuff. So it was like, it was just perfect.
谢谢。现在，你想再拍一个那样的节目，还是你觉得那太特别、太棒了？我甚至不想尝试。太特别了，我甚至不想尝试。那就像是和凯莉合作以及在波特兰拍摄等等的完美结合。所以这就像，这简直太完美了。
Everything that I ever wanted. But that was your baby. Do you want to continue making babies? Like you would never consider doing like silver, like Andia, right? No, nice, nice. Maybe nice. Yeah.
我想要的一切。但那是你的宝贝。你想继续生孩子吗？就像你永远不会考虑做像银色，像安迪亚，对吧？不，不错，不错。也许不错。是的。
Thanks. Sorry, no, it would be Eagle Rock. Sorry, it would be Eagle Rock, Landia. Sorry. Or Highland Park. Highland Park, Andia, you're right, sorry. Sorry, excuse me for my 2004 reference. No, that's okay.
谢谢。抱歉，不，那会是鹰岩。抱歉，那会是鹰岩，兰迪亚。抱歉。或者高地公园。高地公园，安迪亚，你是对的，抱歉。抱歉，请原谅我2004年的引用。不，没关系。
But what feels nice, what feels good is that I feel, I felt so good about Portlandia that whatever the next show I get to do that comes along, I'll be psyched about. Right, but it's like until then you'll do, you'll do actor for hire stuff, but because that was a lot of heavy lifting that you were doing. Yeah, yes.
但感觉不错的是，我感觉，我对《波特兰迪亚》感觉很好，所以无论接下来我能做什么节目，我都会很兴奋。对，但在那之前你会做，你会做雇佣演员的工作，因为那确实是你做的很多重活。是的，是的。
And so it's probably nice to just sit in your trailer and wait for them to call for firsthand. Yes. You were so nice to have me on Portlandia. It's one of my favorite all-time shows. It was such a, I laughed. Oh, you were great. So hard doing that.
所以坐在你的拖车里等他们叫你第一手资料可能很好。是的。你邀请我参加《波特兰迪亚》真是太好了。这是我最喜欢的节目之一。这真是，我笑了。哦，你太棒了。做那个太难了。
Wait, Sean, you were on it? Yes, it was so funny. We did a sketch where we got bad art for coffee shop walls. You know how like coffee shops always have terrible art? Terrible things. Yeah, of course. So we had to look through a bunch of them to find the worst art.
等等，肖恩，你参加了吗？是的，太搞笑了。我们拍了一个小品，我们在咖啡店墙上挂了糟糕的艺术品。你知道咖啡店总是挂着糟糕的艺术品吗？糟糕的东西。是的，当然。所以我们不得不翻看一堆，找出最糟糕的艺术品。
Jason, you and I are the only people that Fred knows who he'd never asked to be on Portlandia. So it says a lot about what he did. No, I think Will, I think Will, we did ask you, couldn't make a deal. And you couldn't do it. Yes, the one time I couldn't do it. So Jason was the only one who's not on it.
杰森，你和我可能是弗雷德认识的唯一从未被邀请参加《波特兰迪亚》的人。所以这说明了他所做的事情。不，我想威尔，我想威尔，我们确实邀请过你，没谈成。你没能参加。是的，唯一一次我没能参加。所以杰森是唯一一个没参加的人。
Jason, are you busy enough? Well, how about you? Let's start with texts. How about just a text? I would love to text with you. I would love to. You know, by the way, Fred and I did this movie called The Rocker years ago with like Bradley Cooper
杰森，你够忙吗？好吧，你呢？我们从短信开始吧。发个短信怎么样？我很乐意和你发短信。我很乐意。你知道，顺便说一下，弗雷德和我在几年前拍过一部电影叫《摇滚者》，和布莱德利·库珀，
and Sedecas and Rainn Wilson and a bunch of people. And we were there for like a week, two days, two weeks, something like that. And that was like, I don't know, 2005 or six, right? Yeah, Toronto, we shot it in Toronto. We were shooting in Toronto. So Sean, he sends me the text. This is from Fred from like two years ago, like 2019.
还有塞德卡斯和雷恩·威尔逊以及一堆人。我们在那儿待了一周，两天，两周，类似那样。那大概是，我不知道，2005年或06年，对吧？是的，多伦多，我们在多伦多拍的。我们在多伦多拍摄。所以肖恩，他给我发了短信。这是弗雷德大约两年前发的，大概是2019年。
I'm in Toronto. Hey, is the Rocker production office still open? Maybe I'll go say hi. 15 years. But isn't there like, don't you feel like that should happen? Like there should always be like some little office somewhere that they're like, hey, just in case, if you have some receipts to bring back or something.
我在多伦多。嘿，摇滚者的制作办公室还开着吗？也许我会去打个招呼。15年了。但难道你不觉得那应该发生吗？就像应该总是有某个小办公室，他们会说，嘿，以防万一，如果你有什么收据要带回来之类的。
We've got some of the props in case you need to get pickups. We're here. As Fred used to do this thing, Amy used to tell me all the time when they were doing SNL, Fred would, and the bigger, the star, the better. They do like the read-through, like the first, you know, the first pitch in Lauren's office. And then Fred would go up to like, you know,
我们有一些道具，以防你需要补拍。我们在这儿。弗雷德过去常做这件事，艾米在他们做《周六夜现场》时总是告诉我，弗雷德会，而且明星越大越好。他们做那种读剧本，就像，你知道，劳恩办公室里的第一次推介。然后弗雷德会走到，你知道，
Tom Hanks or Tom Cruise, whatever, and go, hey, can I get your cell number really quick? Right out of the gate. Right out of the gate. I think I tried to do it to Al Gore because, you know, he was like in the government. Hey, let me get your number. Fred, you seem to be like the most calm.
汤姆·汉克斯或汤姆·克鲁斯，不管是谁，然后说，嘿，我能快速拿到你的手机号码吗？一上来就问。一上来就问。我想我试过对阿尔·戈尔那样做，因为，你知道，他就像在政府里。嘿，让我拿到你的号码。弗雷德，你看起来是最冷静的。
You're always so calm and collected and kind and generous. Have you ever raised your voice or screamed or yelled at anybody in your life? Yeah, sure I have. Well then, so then you've caught it too? I caught it. I caught it. It's a virus.
你总是那么冷静、沉着、善良和慷慨。你这辈子有没有对任何人提高嗓门或尖叫或大喊大叫过？是的，当然有。好吧，那你也中招了？我中招了。我中招了。这是一种病毒。
It's an anger virus. There was one guy walking a dog. I was in Chicago. A guy was walking his dog. A cat came out in front of it and he kicked the cat. Oh my God. No way. Out of the way.
这是一种愤怒病毒。有一个人在遛狗。我在芝加哥。一个人在遛他的狗。一只猫出现在它前面，他踢了那只猫。天哪。不会吧。踢开了。
And I freaked out. I freaked out. Yeah, good. So see, now that guy deserved. He had a cut. Yeah, if somebody has it coming, I will make it very clear how badly you deserve this. I mean, I will at least articulate.
我吓坏了。我吓坏了。是的，很好。所以看，那个人活该。他有一个伤口。是的，如果有人自找的，我会非常清楚地表明你有多么罪有应得。我的意思是，我至少会表达出来。
What did you do? You just screamed your head off, Adam? Yeah. I talk about this idea all the time now with Buddy of Mine. We talk about this idea of, you know, having to go to anger management. And of course, the kind of the workaround is, don't get angry in the first place.
你做了什么？你只是大喊大叫，亚当？是的。我现在总是和我的一个伙伴谈论这个想法。我们谈论这个想法，你知道，不得不去参加愤怒管理。当然，这种变通方法是，首先不要生气。
Because now you're just managing. You're just trying to manage those feelings. And if you can get to the other side of the equation so that you don't get mad in the first place, and people say, well, that's easy enough. But it's kind of true. I don't want to be in a position where I'm having emotions and feelings that I don't like.
因为现在你只是在管理。你只是在试图管理那些情绪。如果你能到达等式的另一边，这样你就不会首先感到愤怒，人们会说，嗯，这很容易。但这有点道理。我不想处于一种我有我不喜欢的感情和情绪的位置。
And now I have to manage those. I don't want to get there in the first place. I just want to say something really, really quick about anger. And I'm not saying this is a good thing to do. Is that I sometimes, the most angry I get is if I have to wait somewhere too long. Say I go to a restaurant and for whatever reason, nothing against the restaurant.
现在我必须管理它们。我不想首先到达那里。我只想快速说点关于愤怒的事情。我不是说这是一个好做法。就是我有时，我最生气的时候是如果我必须在某个地方等太久。假设我去一家餐馆，不管什么原因，不是针对餐馆。
They're too busy. They're understaffed. The way I sometimes express my anger is I just leave. So I'll just simmer for a while. I'm like, oh God, I'm so hungry. And then I'll go, I'm done. I'm just going to go. That's how it works.
他们太忙了。他们人手不足。我有时表达愤怒的方式就是直接离开。所以我只会闷闷不乐一会儿。我想，哦天哪，我太饿了。然后我会说，我受够了。我直接走人。就是这样。
What a monster. What a monster. Take that. What a monster you are. But if I may, that is something that's like, so that's your own thing. So you're getting frustrated. You wish that they were on time.
真是个怪物。真是个怪物。拿去吧。你真是个怪物。但如果可以的话，那是你自己的事情。所以你感到沮丧。你希望他们准时。
They are not on time. And so you're being accountable for your level, your short level of patience, right? So I get that. Only during hunger, yeah. Right, but if somebody does something that is wrong, are you supposed to pretend it didn't happen or ignore it or walk away?
他们不准时。所以你要为你的耐心水平，你的耐心不足负责，对吧？所以我明白。只有在饥饿时，是的。对，但如果有人做了错事，你是应该假装它没发生，还是忽略它，还是走开？
Like, I don't know. I don't know what to do with that. I'm too afraid of violence to like, Well, let's assume somebody's not going to punch you out. I mean, I'm assuming that, you know, we're all civil and, you know, they need to be called out on something. So they don't do that same thing to you again. Well, you're making me a little angry that you're-
比如，我不知道。我不知道该怎么处理。我太害怕暴力了，所以，嗯，让我们假设有人不会揍你。我的意思是，我假设，你知道，我们都很文明，而且，你知道，他们需要被指出错误。这样他们就不会再对你做同样的事情了。嗯，你让我有点生气，你……
Yeah, see. I'm not letting this go. You're not letting it go. And I'm really trying to get, I'm trying to talk to these guys. Okay, Fred. Fred, okay, Fred, just cool it. For once, Fred, because Fred's getting visibly agitated.
是的，看。我不会让这件事过去。你不会让它过去。我真的在努力，我在努力和这些家伙谈话。好吧，弗雷德。弗雷德，好吧，弗雷德，冷静点。弗雷德，就这一次，因为弗雷德明显变得激动了。
It's just, sorry, go ahead, Fred. I cut you off. It's all right. Let's get through these questions real fast. Let's wrap this up. Let's just, contractually, we have to do this. So let's- We have to get to at least 45 minutes.
只是，抱歉，继续，弗雷德。我打断你了。没关系。让我们快速完成这些问题。让我们结束这个。让我们只是，在合同上，我们必须这样做。所以让我们——我们必须至少达到45分钟。
None of us want to. Let's just- Just let's stay civil. None of us. Let's say. None of us want to. Wait, wait, wait, Fred. So Fred tells me, so years ago, we're working in,
我们谁都不想。让我们只是——让我们保持文明。我们谁都不想。让我们说。我们谁都不想。等等，等等，等等，弗雷德。所以弗雷德告诉我，所以几年前，我们在工作，
and Fred goes, we're talking about East Berlin. And he's like, yeah, I was in East Berlin. I go, what do you mean? He goes, wow, my brother lives there. And I go, what? And he goes, yeah, I went across, and I was so crazy. I remember you told me sort of like going camping, and then like they came and checked up on you,
弗雷德说，我们在谈论东柏林。他说，是的，我在东柏林。我说，你什么意思？他说，哇，我兄弟住在那儿。我说，什么？他说，是的，我穿过去了，太疯狂了。我记得你告诉我有点像去露营，然后他们来检查你，
like the military or whatever. Yeah, this is like the 80s when like, you know, both sides were super paranoid. And so my dad had a son before he came to the States. He was in Germany. And my half brother, Fabrizio, was raised in East Germany. So he couldn't leave the Berlin Wall and everything. So I went to go visit him.
比如军队之类的。是的，这就像80年代，你知道，双方都超级偏执。所以我爸爸在来美国之前有一个儿子。他在德国。我同父异母的兄弟，法布里齐奥，是在东德长大的。所以他不能离开柏林墙和所有的一切。所以我去探望他。
Crossed through the, you know, you go through Checkpoint Charlie and they like go through your passport and stamp everything. I was a teenager. And sure enough, when you're there, the Stasi really do kind of like keep an eye on you. They're polite, but they just, they're around a lot. And I was camping up in the northern part of East Germany.
穿过，你知道，你穿过查理检查站，他们检查你的护照并盖章。我当时是个少年。果然，当你在那儿时，史塔西确实有点像在监视你。他们很有礼貌，但他们只是，他们经常在附近。我在东德北部露营。
And they just, you know, open up the zipper of the tent. And they said, let me see your passport. Hello. And what they do is they read your passport back to you. You are Fred Armisen. You live in, you know, and that, and that's it. But I have another, I have another part of this story, Will. Yeah.
他们只是，你知道，拉开帐篷的拉链。他们说，让我看看你的护照。你好。他们做的是把你的护照读给你听。你是弗雷德·阿米森。你住在，你知道，就是这样。但我还有另一个，我还有这个故事的另一部分，威尔。是的。
I might have told, you know what? I think I did tell you about this. Tell me, tell me, tell me. I went back to what is, what used to be East Berlin. And I visited Fabrizio's mom. All right, that's my dad's ex. She went to the Stasi Center to see what they, you know, what information they had on her.
我可能告诉过，你知道吗？我想我确实告诉过你这个。告诉我，告诉我，告诉我。我回到了曾经是东柏林的地方。我拜访了法布里齐奥的妈妈。好吧，那是我爸爸的前妻。她去了史塔西中心看看他们，你知道，他们有什么关于她的信息。
I think I told you this. And she showed me, she made photocopies of pages of books of what they had about her. It's, you know, it's like us going to the CIA or something. And they had photos of the inside of her refrigerator when she wasn't home. No way. No way.
我想我告诉过你这个。她给我看了，她复印了他们关于她的书的页面。这，你知道，这就像我们去中央情报局之类的。他们有她不在家时冰箱内部的照片。不会吧。不会吧。
Photos of just people coming and going and all that stuff. But also like, she's like, look what they took pictures of. Why? So, you know what, so as you know, and right. And Fred, sorry, we talked about this because then I read that book on the Stasi. I read one that you, you told me about and then I told you about one.
人们来来往往的照片等等。但也像，她说，看他们拍了什么照片。为什么？所以，你知道，正如你所知，对。弗雷德，抱歉，我们谈过这个，因为后来我读了那本关于史塔西的书。我读了一本你告诉我的，然后我告诉了你一本。
No, I told you about one. You told me about that one, that I read, yeah. Yeah. And so what they would do is when the wall came down, if you were East German, you were allowed to, whatever files they had not destroyed, you were allowed to go and requisition them and look at your file.
不，我告诉过你一本。你告诉过我那本，我读了，是的。是的。所以当墙倒塌时，如果你是东德人，你被允许，无论他们没有销毁的文件，你被允许去申请并查看你的档案。
And what people found out was friends, neighbors, family were spying on them. So remember, Katarina Witt, the skater, I saw this documentary, she looked at her file finally and in it, it said that her training partner, who is her lifelong friend, this guy, had been informing on her all her life. Oh, wow.
人们发现的是朋友、邻居、家人在监视他们。所以记得卡塔琳娜·维特，那个滑冰运动员，我看了这个纪录片，她终于看了她的档案，里面说她的训练伙伴，她一生的朋友，这个家伙，一直在监视她的一生。哦，哇。
And it divided them, of course, and they haven't spoken since. It was very controversial. And so that's not surprising that your mom, I don't think you did tell me that. And now you're starring in the single camera comedy version of that, aren't you? Yeah, it's so funny.
这当然分裂了他们，他们从此再没说过话。这非常有争议。所以你妈妈那样做并不奇怪，我不认为你告诉过我。现在你正在主演那个的单机位喜剧版本，不是吗？是的，太搞笑了。
Yeah, it's. Isn't it called at my Witt's end? Or did that not clear? Yeah, yeah. At my Witt's end. At my Witt's end. That's nice. With a shrug.
是的，它。不叫《在我的维特尽头》吗？还是没通过？是的，是的。《在我的维特尽头》。《在我的维特尽头》。那很好。耸耸肩。
Yeah. You know, I wonder, I don't want to get political here, but I would like. Oh, let's do it. Yeah, no, let's do it. You want a debate? We've covered anger and now let's do this. And then we're going to do religion right afterwards.
是的。你知道，我想，我不想在这里谈论政治，但我想要。哦，让我们做吧。是的，不，让我们做吧。你想要辩论吗？我们已经讨论了愤怒，现在让我们做这个。然后我们之后会讨论宗教。
Take a position and then Fred, you take the other position. Go. I would probably be very healthy for everybody in this country to know how crazy it is in a lot of parts of this world so that they would appreciate, you know, for as oblong as stuff in our country is sometimes,
采取一个立场，然后弗雷德，你采取另一个立场。开始。让这个国家的每个人都知道这个世界的许多地方有多疯狂，这可能对每个人都非常健康，这样他们就会感激，你知道，尽管我们国家的事情有时很混乱，
it's still frigging fantastic. And we're all one, even though we don't, like maybe it would just be a nice unifier. I know at least me just going out of the country and vacationing and having a great time. I, when I come back, America's never been more beautiful to me. But like when you hear stories about like,
它仍然非常棒。我们都是一体的，即使我们不，也许这会是一个很好的统一者。我知道至少我离开这个国家去度假并玩得很开心。我，当我回来时，美国对我来说从未如此美丽。但当你听到关于，
how do governments get to a point where they actually recruit your family members to spy? I mean, granted that was back in the Cold War, but you know, it's still, it happens around the world. It's in my lifetime. It's not, you know, it's a long time ago, but not, it's in my memory. And also that I couldn't meet my half brother
政府怎么会达到招募你的家人来监视你的地步？我的意思是，诚然那是冷战时期，但你知道，它仍然，它发生在世界各地。它在我的一生中。它不是，你知道，那是很久以前的事了，但不是，它在我的记忆中。而且我也不能见我同父异母的兄弟，
because he couldn't leave. There was a wall. They had a physical wallet. He just, you know. Wait, so you never met your brother? Oh yeah, yeah. Now we're in touch. Now I've visited him and stuff.
因为他不能离开。有一堵墙。他们有一堵物理墙。他只是，你知道。等等，所以你从未见过你兄弟？哦是的，是的。现在我们有联系了。现在我拜访过他之类的。
Now you wish there was a wall. Now you wish they put the wall back in. Right? Am I right or am I wrong? Yeah, this guy, but basically. I was thinking about being political. I was thinking, Freddie, about your character. What was his name? Nicholas Fenn?
现在你希望有一堵墙。现在你希望他们把墙放回去。对吧？我是对的还是错的？是的，这个家伙，但基本上。我在想政治。我在想，弗雷迪，关于你的角色。他叫什么名字？尼古拉斯·芬？
Oh, Nicholas Fenn, yeah. Nicholas Fenn. Oh my God. Do you remember that character Freddie used to do on SNL where he was a political comedian? Yes, so funny. Oh my God. And he was just, he couldn't finish a sentence.
哦，尼古拉斯·芬，是的。尼古拉斯·芬。天哪。你还记得弗雷迪过去在《周六夜现场》做的那个角色吗，他是一个政治喜剧演员？是的，太搞笑了。天哪。他只是，他无法完成一个句子。
And he would, he would pull out the New York Times and the Wall Street Journal. And he'd go like, here we go, here we go. People, New York State says to adjust the budget. I was thinking about you guys when I saw it. So, and then he would just never finish what he was saying. No thought was ever finished. You know, and then it would tape off and do,
他会，他会拿出《纽约时报》和《华尔街日报》。他会说，我们开始吧，我们开始吧。人们，纽约州说要调整预算。我看到它时想到了你们。所以，然后他永远不会完成他正在说的话。没有一个想法是完成的。你知道，然后它会逐渐消失并做，
you know, I had an uncle and it had nothing to do with what was being said. And we will be right back. Now, I'm sure you get this question a lot, so I apologize, but just hearing that story, it made me think like, do you, you have to miss the sort of the lab, the factory of, you can just think up
你知道，我有一个叔叔，这和正在说的话毫无关系。我们马上回来。现在，我相信你经常被问到这个问题，所以我道歉，但听到那个故事，它让我想到，你，你必须怀念那种实验室，工厂，你可以想出，
some crazy character like that and you can get it on its feet and maybe even make it to national broadcast by Saturday and then it's gone. Like, do you miss being in that weekly environment and opportunity? Yeah, you know, I mean, I did it for long enough that I'm not like pining to, you know,
一些像那样的疯狂角色，你可以让它站稳脚跟，甚至可能在周六之前进入全国广播，然后它就消失了。比如，你怀念那种每周的环境和机会吗？是的，你知道，我的意思是，我做了足够长的时间，我不像是在渴望，你知道，
go back in time in that way. But yeah, I do miss not having that immediacy of just like any dumb idea all of a sudden was being, not also not just being produced, but you're getting to do it with your friends. Right. And then they're adding to it and they're laughing. And yeah, I mean, that was just like right away.
以那种方式回到过去。但是的，我确实怀念没有那种即时性，就像任何愚蠢的想法突然之间被，不仅是被制作出来，而且你还能和你的朋友一起做。对。然后他们加入进去，他们在大笑。是的，我的意思是，那简直就是立刻。
What was that process for your friend? Cause I'm a little unclear. So you, I'm right that you were, of course you still are a musician and you were a drummer and then you, where did, how did you start doing sketch? Like, where did that come in? I just started doing,
那个过程对你朋友来说是什么样的？因为我有点不清楚。所以你，我是对的，你曾经，当然你现在仍然是一位音乐家，你是一位鼓手，然后你，你是从哪里，你是怎么开始做小品的？那是从哪里来的？我只是开始做，
I played drums and bands for a long time and wasn't getting very far. It was a lot of work and we'd go on tour and not that many people would come out. But when I started doing comedy, like making these little videos and stuff, this is pre-internet, I just got asked to do more and more stuff.
我打鼓和乐队待了很长时间，并没有取得多大进展。那做了很多工作，我们去巡演，没有多少人出来。但当我开始做喜剧时，比如制作这些小视频之类的，这是互联网之前，我只是被要求做越来越多的事情。
And then I would do like some kind of standup where like I would do a character at Largo or something. And then, and then I had enough tape to audition for SNL. Audition for SNL, part of that by the way was a pilot that Bob Odenkirk did called Next, a sketch show. And- Who was in that with you? Do you remember?
然后我会做一些单口相声，比如我在拉戈做个角色之类的。然后，然后我有足够的录像带去试镜《周六夜现场》。试镜《周六夜现场》，顺便说一下，那部分是鲍勃·奥登科克做的一个试播集，叫《下一个》，一个短剧节目。谁和你一起参加了？你记得吗？
Nick Swartzson, Jay Johnston, Bob, Dave did a couple of things on there. So because of, anyway. And was that because of like Largo, like you were doing stuff and Bob identified you and said, hey, would you come and do this pilot with us? Yeah, yes, that's exactly. He's the one who really got me on TV.
尼克·斯瓦茨森，杰伊·约翰斯顿，鲍勃，戴夫在上面做了一些事情。所以因为，无论如何。那是为了像拉戈，比如你在做一些事情，鲍勃认出了你并说，嘿，你愿意来和我们一起做这个试播集吗？是的，是的，完全正确。他是真正让我上电视的人。
Oh man, oh man, what a friend, oh! And so when you say you're doing videos but before the internet, what does that mean? Like you'd literally like make short little movies on VHS tapes and send them around? Yeah, of me as different characters interviewing bands. And then you'd make a bunch of copies of those tapes and send out multiple tapes or-
天哪，天哪，多好的朋友，哦！所以当你说是你在做视频但在互联网之前，那是什么意思？比如你字面上像是在VHS录像带上制作短小电影并到处发送？是的，我作为不同角色采访乐队的。然后你会制作一堆那些录像带的副本并发送多份录像带或者——
Yeah, just like records or something. Like I'd make dubs of these videos. Do you have an agent or anything like that at that time? No, no, no, no. I was just a drummer. Oh yeah, nobody, nothing. I love that you are a drummer. I'm such a drum fan and freak.
是的，就像唱片之类的。比如我会制作这些视频的配音。你当时有经纪人或类似的人吗？不，不，不，不。我只是个鼓手。哦是的，没有人，什么都没有。我喜欢你是个鼓手。我是一个鼓迷和狂热者。
I wish I knew how to play. I play my steering wheel all the time, but I can't- Well- What is that? It's called independence, right? Where you're, the bass drum goes at a different time as the hi-hat and I can't separate those. So first of all, it's never too late
我希望我知道怎么玩。我一直敲我的方向盘，但我不能——嗯——那是什么？这叫独立性，对吧？就是，低音鼓和踩镲在不同的时间，我无法分开它们。所以首先，永远不会太晚，
and it's supposed to be a fun instrument. So all that stuff about it being like so precise and stuff, it doesn't matter. Fred, it's not surprising you're a drummer because you do have maybe the best, one of the better timings of anybody around. So it always added up to me. I mean that in a way.
而且它应该是一种有趣的乐器。所以所有关于它非常精确之类的说法，都没关系。弗雷德，你是个鼓手并不奇怪，因为你确实有可能是周围人中最好的节奏感之一。所以这对我来说总是说得通。我的意思是，以某种方式。
I've always thought that like, oh yeah, there's something musical about, Sean, you're the same way, you're very musical. Like you understand rhythm and all that kind of stuff. They're very closely connected music and comedy. Explain it to me. I'm so sorry that I cut you in the face. I'm so sorry that I cut you in the face.
我一直认为，哦是的，音乐有一些东西，肖恩，你也是一样，你非常有音乐感。比如你理解节奏和所有那种东西。它们联系非常紧密，音乐和喜剧。给我解释一下。我很抱歉我打断了你的脸。我很抱歉我打断了你的脸。
No, one second while I get this in. Tell us how it's the same. So with the rhythm, just like one, two, three, four. Sure. It's so boring. Oh, Fred, favorite drummer of all time? John Bonham, great choice. Great choice.
不，等我把这个放进去。告诉我们它们是怎么一样的。所以关于节奏，就像一，二，三，四。当然。太无聊了。哦，弗雷德，史上最喜欢的鼓手？约翰·博纳姆，很好的选择。很好的选择。
Good, good. Oh yeah, that's a great choice. And favorite band, the Beatles, right? I mean, what the fuck, man? Come on, what the fuck? What is this? Sorry guys, I'm really not asking great questions. What is this?
好，好。哦是的，那是个很好的选择。还有最喜欢的乐队，披头士，对吧？我的意思是，搞什么鬼，伙计？得了吧，搞什么鬼？这是什么？抱歉伙计们，我真的没问什么好问题。这是什么？
Favorite movie, favorite movie, The Godfather. What? Godfather, what? So what? Guys, I apologize. This is non-information. This is non-information. Wait, Fred.
最喜欢的电影，最喜欢的电影，《教父》。什么？教父，什么？那又怎样？伙计们，我道歉。这是无用信息。这是无用信息。等等，弗雷德。
Citizen Kane's the greatest movie of all time. Okay, well, thanks a lot, man. And there's our show. Favorite director, Scorsese. Oh, wow. I didn't expect that. Hey, listen, not a lot of people know John Bonham's. Fred, do you play something other than the drums?
《公民凯恩》是史上最伟大的电影。好吧，好吧，多谢了，伙计。这就是我们的节目。最喜欢的导演，斯科塞斯。哦，哇。我没想到。嘿，听着，没多少人知道约翰·博纳姆的。弗雷德，你除了鼓还玩别的吗？
Or no, just drums? My favorite drummer, I would say, I have to ignore your questions, Sean. I have to. No, I get it. Sean, you gotta shut up, guy. It's okay. I'm crossing them off as a...
还是不，只是鼓？我最喜欢的鼓手，我会说，我必须忽略你的问题，肖恩。我必须。不，我明白了。肖恩，你得闭嘴，伙计。没关系。我把它们划掉作为……
They don't need to be answered. I just have... I'm legally obligated. I like that you really have a pencil. Yeah, nice. My favorite drummer, I would say it's Klemberg from Blondie, and then Keith Moon, also. Oh, yeah.
它们不需要被回答。我只是有……我法律上有义务。我喜欢你真的有一支铅笔。是的，不错。我最喜欢的鼓手，我会说是布隆迪的克伦伯格，然后还有基思·穆恩。哦，是的。
Sure, sure. Keith Moon. Keith Moon from what? The Who, you Philistine. Yeah. And also, do I play anything else? I play some guitar and some bass. Sure.
当然，当然。基思·穆恩。基思·穆恩是谁？谁乐队，你这个庸俗的人。是的。还有，我玩别的吗？我玩一些吉他和一些贝斯。当然。
Okay, that's great. That would see, you answer the question. Will Arnett, Will Arnett plays the air bass. You ever seen Will play the air bass? I do really well. Really well. Are you guys musicians? You guys are musicians, right?
好吧，那太棒了。那会看，你回答了问题。威尔·阿内特，威尔·阿内特玩空气贝斯。你见过威尔玩空气贝斯吗？我做得很好。真的很好。你们是音乐家吗？你们是音乐家，对吧？
Sean is. Sean is. Sean is. Go ahead, Sean. Sean, what do you play? Sorry, do you consider musical theater to fall in that category? You sang in the movie, you sang in the rocker.
肖恩是。肖恩是。肖恩是。继续，肖恩。肖恩，你玩什么？抱歉，你认为音乐剧属于那个类别吗？你在电影里唱过，你在《摇滚者》里唱过。
Yeah, I know, I sang, I did. I sang in the movie. How about that? The rocker. Oh my God. Will, I've never heard you sing. Just do Happy Birthday for a second. It's terrible, but Fred came in
是的，我知道，我唱了，我做了。我在电影里唱了。那怎么样？《摇滚者》。天哪。威尔，我从没听过你唱歌。就做一秒钟的《生日快乐》。这很糟糕，但弗雷德进来了，
and he placed the bassist in the rocker, and he kept doing this gross move that all those bands used to do where he would spin around with the fucking bass, and it would make me, it would always take me out of it because it would make me laugh so hard. My favorite thing that you do, Will,
他扮演了《摇滚者》里的贝斯手，他一直做那个所有那些乐队过去常做的恶心动作，他会带着该死的贝斯转圈，这会让我，它总是让我出戏，因为它让我笑得太厉害了。威尔，你最喜欢做的事情，
when you do air bass, is not only will you tune it, right? So you bring the hand up on top and tune, and then back on, and everything, but then you do this thing where you go, okay, and then you know how the bass player always catches the eyes of the lead singer, and then it's a double knee bend. So he's just chilling, right?
当你玩空气贝斯时，不仅你会调音，对吧？所以你把手举到上面调音，然后放回去，所有的一切，但然后你做这个动作，你说，好吧，然后你知道贝斯手总是捕捉主唱的眼睛，然后是一个双膝弯曲。所以他只是在放松，对吧？
He's chilling, right? He's playing bass with the band, and then all of a sudden the lead singer happens to cut the middle song, give him a little, and he just goes. Yeah, and then he does basically like a curtsy, double knee curtsy, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
他在放松，对吧？他和乐队一起弹贝斯，然后突然主唱碰巧切断了中间的歌，给他一点，然后他就直接。是的，然后他基本上做了一个屈膝礼，双膝屈膝礼，是的。是的，是的，是的。
So Freddie, so you do this sketch show with Bob and those guys, and then you get enough tape together to submit to SNL, and you audition in L.A. for SNL, or you go to New York first? New York. So you go to New York.
所以Freddie，你和Bob还有那些家伙一起做那个短剧节目，然后你攒够了录像带寄给SNL，接着你在洛杉矶为SNL试镜，还是你先去了纽约？纽约。所以你去了纽约。
Lauren doesn't see you in L.A., you just go to New York. Go to New York. And had that been a dream of yours to be on the show? Like, had you always been like, oh my God, I'd kill to be on Serent Live, or was it just like another audition? Or did you have sexy indifference?
Lauren没在洛杉矶见你，你直接去了纽约。去了纽约。那曾是你的梦想吗，想上那个节目？比如，你一直以来是不是都觉得，天哪，我为了能上《周六夜现场》什么都愿意做，还是说那只是又一次试镜？或者你当时表现得满不在乎？
No, it was more like, I always loved SNL. I loved it. So it was just like, it was so mind-blowingly crazy of an idea that I was thrilled, but it wasn't even in my... No pressure, because it really, like this ain't gonna happen. Exactly what it was like.
不，更像是，我一直很喜欢SNL。我太喜欢它了。所以这对我来说简直是个异想天开的想法，我当时很兴奋，但它甚至都不在我的……没有压力，因为真的，这事儿不可能发生。当时就是这种感觉。
I was thrilled enough to be at that studio auditioning, because I was still kind of like, I was only a couple of years away from having been a drummer and a band. So I was like, oh, I'm at NBC. They paid for my plane ticket. This is crazy. I got a free plane ticket.
我当时能在那间演播室试镜就已经很兴奋了，因为我当时离我做乐队鼓手也就才过去几年。所以我当时想，哦，我在NBC。他们还付了我的机票钱。这太疯狂了。我拿到了一张免费机票。
And then I think it really did help me relax in the audition, where I felt like this is incredible. But the first one was at UCB, and then it was at the studio. Like, they started... UCB on 26th Street under the tennis bubble, that one? Yeah. No, no.
然后我觉得这确实帮我在试镜时放松了下来，我当时觉得这太不可思议了。但第一次是在UCB，然后是在演播室。他们开始……UCB在26街网球气膜馆下面那个？对。不，不。
It was the one before that one. Oh, the one on 22nd? Yeah. Before they got kicked out of there. Oh, no kidding. Yeah, yeah. That's right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是那个之前的那个。哦，22街那个？对。在他们被赶出来之前。哦，不是吧。是啊，是啊。没错。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
One of my favorite things about when Fred was on SNL, apart from just being a delight and being hilarious, and I loved seeing him all the time. Well, you're so nice. Thanks, buddy. But Fred knew all the musicians, too. And they all knew Fred. So it would always be like,
关于Fred在SNL的那段日子，我最喜欢的一点，除了他本人很讨人喜欢又搞笑，而且我一直很喜欢见到他之外。嗯，你太客气了。谢谢，伙计。但Fred也认识所有的音乐人。他们也都认识Fred。所以总是会变成这样，
Fred would be like, oh, hey, do you know Jeff Tweety? And I'd be like, no, I don't. But I'm really happy to be talking with him from Wilco, or you knew all the guys from like the Shins, or you knew that, you know what I mean? Like you knew all those guys. That was kind of your world a little bit. And SNL was like a weird sort of crossroads
Fred会说，哦，嘿，你认识Jeff Tweety吗？我会说，不，我不认识。但我很高兴能和他聊天，他是Wilco乐队的，或者你认识The Shins乐队的所有人，或者你知道的，你懂我的意思吗？就像你认识所有那些人。那在某种程度上算是你的世界。而SNL就像是一个奇怪的十字路口，
of kind of both your past and your present in a way. Yeah. Did you ever get involved in the booking of the bands? Did they ever, did they ever take your suggestions or your advice at all? Oh, only later, just like in mentioning a band to them, but not, I don't think during my run there, really. It was only like towards the end,
在某种程度上结合了你的过去和现在。是啊。你有没有参与过乐队的预订？他们有没有采纳过你的建议或意见？哦，只有后来，就像向他们推荐某个乐队，但我觉得在我工作期间并没有。只有在快结束的时候，
where I was a little more loose about recommending bands and stuff. I wonder what that process is. I wonder how much of that is like influence from labels or like how they go about picking. It's really weird. It's, a lot of it is like mysterious, but some of it is just like a weird timing thing
我才稍微随意地推荐了一些乐队之类的。我很好奇那个过程是什么样的。我很好奇其中有多少是受唱片公司影响，或者他们是怎么挑选的。真的很奇怪。很多时候都很神秘，但有些时候只是一个奇怪的时机问题，
of like this seems right right now. Yeah. Like the hosts, right? And it's not even necessarily having a hit. It's just like a weird timing thing of like, they are in the ether right now in just the right way. About to break or something. Yeah, and then you learn,
比如现在看起来很合适。对。就像主持人一样，对吧？甚至不一定非要有热门歌曲。只是一个奇怪的时机问题，比如，他们现在正以一种恰到好处的方式出现在大众视野里。快要火了之类的。对，然后你就会发现，
a lot of people learn about them from that show. I always did. I always watched SNL and I still do. I watch it all the time. I never miss an episode. I love it. Wow, that's great. Is there somebody on there right now
很多人都是通过那个节目认识他们的。我一直都是。我一直看SNL，现在也看。我一直都在看。我从不错过任何一集。我太喜欢它了。哇，那太棒了。现在节目里有没有谁
that you particularly find extra talented or? Oh man, I really love this cast. I think Beck Bennett is really funny. Heidi Gardner, it's such a cliche thing to say, but they are all great. Yeah. You know, someone on the cast will come up with some sketch or something on update
是你觉得特别有才华的，或者？天哪，我真的很喜欢现在的卡司。我觉得Beck Bennett真的很搞笑。Heidi Gardner，说这话虽然很老套，但他们都很棒。是啊。你知道，卡司里的某个人会想出一些短剧或者在新闻播报环节里的一些东西，
that is just is incredible. I love it. I love that show. Was that your favorite part doing, getting to kind of, because you did a lot of sketches, but going to do characters on update, that's where you,
简直太不可思议了。我喜欢它。我喜欢那个节目。那是你做节目时最喜欢的部分吗，因为你做了很多短剧，但去新闻播报环节演角色，那是你，
I feel like you were, not a lot of people can pull it off. And it was something that you seem to enjoy a lot. Like it looked like you really enjoyed doing those characters on update. Yeah, that was kind of like, it was just an easy way in where I didn't have to explain it.
我觉得你是，没几个人能驾驭得了。而且那似乎是你很享受的事情。看起来你真的很喜欢在新闻播报环节演那些角色。是啊，那就像是一种简单的切入方式，我不需要解释什么。
And also where a whole sketch didn't have to lean on me. Right. And I think that's also like, I also don't think I have that kind of energy to be the center of a sketch like that. You know, some people have that energy where they can really like hold it together.
而且整个短剧也不需要完全靠我来支撑。对。而且我觉得这也是，我也不觉得我有那种精力去成为那种短剧的核心。你知道，有些人有那种精力，他们真的能撑住场子。
But I think for me, it worked out a little better on update where it's a shorter amount of time. And it's just the character being, you know, crazy in his own way. Have you always wanted to be that? Have you always wanted to be kind of like part of an ensemble and something?
但我认为对我来说，在新闻播报环节效果更好，因为时间更短。而且只是角色以他自己的方式表现得疯狂而已。你一直想成为那样的人吗？你一直想成为那种 ensemble（群戏）的一部分吗？
Never like the leading guy out in front all the time? No, never. No, it's like a really comfortable spot for me. It's the drummer mentality, right? And it is very much like being a drummer. It's like same kind of thing, you know, in the back, but still making a lot of noise and hitting cymbals and stuff.
从来没想过一直做领衔主演吗？不，从来没有。不，那对我来说是一个非常舒服的位置。这就是鼓手心态，对吧？这确实很像做鼓手。就像同样的事情，你知道，在后面，但仍然制造出很大的噪音，敲击镲片之类的。
But, you know, nothing without the rest of the band. I just prefer it. But then you leave, so then you leave SNL after like 11 years, I want to say. Yeah, yeah. And you and Cary Brownstein create Portlandia, which was kind of, first of all, a phenomenal show we talked about
但是，你知道，没有乐队的其他成员，什么都不是。我只是更喜欢这样。但后来你离开了，你在SNL待了大概11年，我想说。是啊，是啊。然后你和Cary Brownstein创作了《波特兰迪亚》，那简直是，首先，我们在节目开头谈到的那部现象级的剧，
at the top of the show here, but it's such a phenomenal show. So funny, Fred. Oh, thanks, man. Yeah, I mean, you got to, it was a great way for you to kind of, it was almost like a natural progression of doing your characters that you do on update
但它确实是一部现象级的剧。太搞笑了，Fred。哦，谢谢，伙计。是啊，我的意思是，你得，这对你来说是一个很好的方式，几乎就像是你做新闻播报环节那些角色的自然延伸，
and then going in, I guess, just kind of beating them out a little bit more and giving them a little air. And, but it does go sort of counter to that thing. Like you and Cary carried that show together, but it was really important for you or friend center, like you, you know, every, virtually every scene of every show for the most part.
然后进去，我想，只是把它们稍微打磨一下，给它们一点空间。而且，这确实有点违背那个原则。你和Cary一起撑起了那部剧，但这对你来说真的很重要，或者说以朋友为中心，就像你，你知道，几乎每一集的每一个场景，大部分时间都是。
Yeah, but we split it. At least we split as opposed to it just being like, just me. Talking about your relationship with Cary in that. So how did you and Cary sort of come together? Because she, Cary Brownstein, of course, fantastic musician in, you know, she's been in the band Slater Kinney for a long time and incredible band.
是啊，但我们分担了。至少我们分担了，而不是只有我一个人。谈谈你和Cary在那部剧里的关系。那么你和Cary是怎么走到一起的呢？因为她，Cary Brownstein，当然，是一位出色的音乐人，你知道，她长期在Sleter Kinney乐队，那是一支不可思议的乐队。
And then how was it that she all of a sudden- Yeah, how did you guys meet? Yeah, how did you guys create that? Well, in the nineties, Slater Kinney, or they still are my favorite band. And I knew the drummer, Janet Weiss. So I knew Janet in the late nineties. And would stay in touch with her and stuff.
然后她是怎么突然——是啊，你们是怎么认识的？是啊，你们是怎么创作出那部剧的？嗯，在九十年代，Sleter Kinney，或者她们现在仍然是我最喜欢的乐队。我认识鼓手Janet Weiss。所以我九十年代末就认识Janet了。也会和她保持联系之类的。
And then when in the early 2000s, Slater Kinney came to play in New York, I couldn't go to the show because of SNL, but I was like, why don't you come to the party instead? And I met Cary at this party. We already knew each other kind of. Like we knew a lot of the same people, you know, the band is from Portland.
然后当21世纪初，Sleter Kinney来纽约演出时，我因为SNL没法去看演出，但我说，不如你来参加派对吧？我在那个派对上遇到了Cary。我们其实已经认识了。就像我们认识很多共同的朋友，你知道，那个乐队来自波特兰。
And it was just this immediate thing where I just knew we were gonna be friends. I was like, this is gonna be, I just know it. And it turned out to be true. Like we just, it was an immediate thing. And I would go visit her in Portland. And it was the thing of like, I didn't want to be like, let's start a band.
那是一种即时的感觉，我知道我们会成为朋友。我当时想，这会是，我就是知道。结果证明确实如此。就像我们，那是一种即时的感觉。我会去波特兰看她。当时的感觉就是，我不想说，让我们组个乐队吧。
It's such a, you know, it's so expected. Like, yeah, we put out a single. So I was like, why don't we just shoot some videos and just put them online? And that's how we started doing it. So we would do them in Portland and we just put them up on this site. And all of a sudden we had enough of these videos.
这太，你知道，太理所当然了。就像，是的，我们发一张单曲。所以我说，不如我们拍一些视频，直接放到网上吧？这就是我们开始做的方式。所以我们在波特兰拍了视频，然后把它们放到了这个网站上。突然之间，我们有了足够多的视频。
Some of it was like the feminist bookstore and all kinds of stuff. And those sort of they ended up being on the show. We had enough to like make a pilot. So when my manager was like, what's the next thing you want to do? Is I was like, I have enough of these videos. Why don't we just turn this into a show
有些是关于女权主义书店之类的各种东西。那些最终都出现在了节目里。我们有足够的素材来拍试播集。所以当我的经纪人问，你接下来想做什么？我说，我有足够多的这些视频了。不如我们把它变成一个节目，
and then we pitched it. And- Was that the first time she was on camera acting and stuff like that? Like, how did, was she comfortable with all that stuff? She's done a couple little thing, little. I mean, like she did a commercial once and, but I guess a sketch comedy was like her first thing.
然后我们就去推销了。那是她第一次在镜头前演戏之类的吗？她是怎样，她对所有这些感到自在吗？她做过一些小事情，一点点。我的意思是，她曾经拍过一个广告，但我想短剧喜剧是她的第一次。
Yeah. She wasn't looking to be an actor. She was, she was a musician. And so like when you said, let's, let's do something on camera, did she, did she balk at all at that? No, she for some reason, it just seemed, it made sense. Also that we were in Portland, you know.
是啊。她并不是想成为一名演员。她是，她是一名音乐人。所以当你提议说，让我们在镜头前做点什么时，她有没有退缩？没有，她出于某种原因，这看起来很合理。而且我们当时在波特兰，你知道。
You're in Portland, you guys have good chemistry, I guess. So that probably made her feel at ease, right? In that way, like- Yeah, there were, also there was like no pressure on it. It was, there was no goal. It was just like, let's just make these videos that we think are funny and that'll be enough. And then you guys were like, let's, let's make this show
你们在波特兰，你们有很好的化学反应，我想。所以这可能让她感到轻松，对吧？以那种方式，就像——是啊，而且也没有压力。没有目标。只是，让我们拍一些我们觉得好笑的视频，这就足够了。然后你们就说，让我们做这个节目，
and let's give half, half of the money to Lauren. Let's give half of the money to Lauren. Nice of you. I still, I still try to pay him. I still try to send him whatever- No way! Hell yes. Always help, always help.
然后把一半的钱给Lauren。把一半的钱给Lauren。你真好。我仍然，我仍然试图付钱给他。我仍然试图寄给他任何——没门！该死，是的。总是帮忙，总是帮忙。
So, so when, so when, so when you started on SNL, was that the first time that you were spending significant time in New York City? And if so, how, how did you like the city? How did you like that life? I'm originally from Long Island where like, I was close enough to the city that we would, I would go in, you know, or my family would go in.
所以，所以当你开始在SNL工作时，那是你第一次在纽约市待很长时间吗？如果是的话，你觉得这个城市怎么样？你喜欢那种生活吗？我原本来自长岛，离城市很近，所以我们会，我会进去，你知道，或者我的家人会进去。
Okay. But living in Manhattan was great. I lived up on the Upper West Side and- That's where I am right now. I thought you lived in LA. And by the way, by the way, he's on the Upper West Side and I'm on Long Island. True story.
好的。但住在曼哈顿很棒。我住在上西区，然后——我现在就在那儿。我以为你住在洛杉矶。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，他在上西区，我在长岛。真实的故事。
There you go. Are you really? Yeah, yeah. What are you doing on Long Island? In your childhood at home, we're making documentary about your life. Oh wow. And it starts there.
你看。你真的在吗？是啊，是啊。你在长岛做什么？在你童年的家里，我们正在制作一部关于你生活的纪录片。哦，哇。而且是从那里开始的。
So that's why we're doing the, yeah. And it's so fucking, we were just in your room. We do really long takes where we just let the film roll out. And we let the film in it. Oh nice. And it's kind of like, and it's just a lot of slow pans around your room because it's still intact.
所以这就是为什么我们在做，是啊。而且太他妈的了，我们刚才还在你的房间里。我们拍了很长的镜头，只是让胶片一直转。我们让胶片在里面。哦，不错。而且就像是，只是有很多缓慢的平移镜头扫过你的房间，因为它还保持原样。
So we just a lot of like slow pans, right? And we're going to have very little scores. It's going to be quite dry. It's going to be quite dry. Yeah. By the way, how great are documentaries in general? Can we talk about that? Sure.
所以我们只是做了很多缓慢的平移，对吧？而且我们会有很少的配乐。会相当枯燥。会相当枯燥。是啊。顺便说一句，纪录片总体来说有多棒？我们可以谈谈这个吗？当然。
Well, let's just go ahead and go into that subject. They're great. What's your favorite documentary? They're all great. I don't have, I don't do favorites with documentaries. I think they're all- Oh, but then you did another series that- But then you did documentary now,
好吧，让我们直接进入那个话题。它们很棒。你最喜欢的纪录片是什么？它们都很棒。我没有，我不给纪录片排最爱。我觉得它们都——哦，但后来你做了另一个系列，那——但后来你做了《纪录片现在》，
it shows how much respect you really have for documentaries. How dare you, Fred? But Jason, I feel like I skipped over. You were asking me a real question and then I just did a bit. Well, you know, because Will started with obviously shitty research saying that you were born in Mississippi. And so I thought, well, New York City will probably be-
这显示了你对纪录片有多么尊重。你怎么敢，Fred？但Jason，我觉得我跳过了。你刚才在问我一个真正的问题，然后我只是做了一个小段子。好吧，你知道，因为Will一开始显然做了烂透了的研究，说你出生在密西西比州。所以我以为，好吧，纽约市可能会是——
No, that's true. Okay. Oh, that's true. Yeah, we'll cut that out. No, we'll cut that out. We'll cut that out. I was born there and then my parents moved up to New York. So then I was raised on my own.
不，那是真的。好吧。哦，那是真的。是啊，我们会剪掉那个。不，我们会剪掉那个。我们会剪掉那个。我出生在那里，然后我父母搬到了纽约。所以我是在自己长大的。
It's called moving, Jason. It's called, people don't just stay, you're not like born here and now you got to stay here forever. In Germany you do, yes. And he's Germany. He's been here forever. Germany for sure.
这叫搬家，Jason。这叫，人们不会一直待着，你不是那种出生在这里，现在就得永远待在这里的人。在德国是这样，是的。他是德国人。他一直在这儿。德国肯定是的。
Yeah, you're not going anywhere. No, it'd be nice. You can look over it if your window's high enough. All those dirty American Levi's you have on? Oh, where'd you get them? Oh, she got some Levi's. That's what we used to have to bring as presents. Jeans.
是啊，你哪儿也去不了。不，那会很不错。如果你的窗户够高，你可以俯瞰它。你穿的所有那些脏兮兮的美国Levi's牛仔裤？哦，你从哪儿弄来的？哦，她弄到了一些Levi's。那曾经是我们必须带的礼物。牛仔裤。
The Levi's. Sure. Got some cool jeans, man. Hey, look at this guy's got some cool jeans and he's kicking and he's got some really nice Dracar Noir. Okay, here we are spitting out all the hits. He's German. He's favorite record station.
Levi's。当然。弄到了一些很酷的牛仔裤，伙计。嘿，看这个家伙穿了一些很酷的牛仔裤，他在踢腿，而且他身上有很棒的Dracar Noir香水味。好吧，我们在这里把所有的热门话题都吐出来了。他是德国人。他最喜欢的唱片站。
Falko. Hamadass. Uh-oh. Again, do you hear me? I was playing rock, man. Hamadass. I heard, yes. I heard.
Falko。Hamadass。噢噢。再说一次，你听见我了吗？我在放摇滚乐，伙计。Hamadass。我听到了，是的。我听到了。
And you were talking about waiting rooms and doctor's offices and. I know. Sean wants to get back into the waiting room. Sean doesn't like to waste time in waiting rooms. He likes to. I know, but what I don't understand is that Sean says he goes 15 minutes early, but like.
你刚才在谈论候诊室和医生办公室。我知道。Sean想回到候诊室。Sean不喜欢在候诊室浪费时间。他喜欢。我知道，但我无法理解的是，Sean说他提前15分钟去，但就像。
No, 15 minutes later. Oh, late. But how do you even time that out? Because it's so difficult parking and like getting the right elevator and all that stuff. How do you time exactly that 15 minutes late? Getting the right elevator. Really carefully.
不，晚15分钟。哦，迟到。但你怎么能掐准那个时间呢？因为停车太难了，还要找对电梯之类的。你怎么能正好迟到15分钟？找对电梯。非常小心。
Don't you feel like every doctor visit is like, where am I going? No, because I go so frequently. Yeah, are you guys sick? What's going on? Do you go to the doctor a lot? I do. I do.
你不觉得每次看医生都像，我要去哪儿？不，因为我去得很频繁。是啊，你们生病了吗？怎么了？你们经常去看医生吗？我去看。我去看。
I like to check in all the time. How's my blood doing? How's my foot doing? How's my back doing? Well, how, what, so are you, Sean, are you one of those guys that gets your, your annual physical every year? I don't wait probably that long.
我喜欢一直检查。我的血液怎么样？我的脚怎么样？我的背怎么样？好吧，那么，Sean，你是那种每年做年度体检的人吗？我可能不会等那么久。
I probably go a couple of times a year. Come on now. Are you being serious? Yeah, I'm being totally serious. You're talking about full blood panels and you're on the fucking treadmill and you've got a lot of hoses on you and stuff. Well, how about this?
我可能一年去几次。得了吧。你是认真的吗？是啊，我是完全认真的。你在说全套血液检查，你在他妈的跑步机上，身上连着很多管子之类的。好吧，那这个呢？
I went and he goes, have you been feeling tired lately? I go, yeah, you're, you're at thyroid level as low. So I started taking. This guy knows he's got a live one on his hands. That's all he's just going to train you. Talk about second home. This guy built a fucking, are you kidding?
我去了，他说，你最近觉得累吗？我说，是啊，你的甲状腺水平很低。所以我开始吃药了。这家伙知道他手里有个活宝。他只会训练你。谈谈第二个家。这家伙建了一个他妈的，你在开玩笑吗？
You know, you know, my next patient, he's actually got a podcast called about fucking hypochondria. And just this guy is a cash cow. Make him wait 15 minutes and then bring him in to see me. It's unbelievable. Uh-huh, yep, that's me. You feeling tired?
你知道，你知道，我的下一个病人，他其实有个关于他妈的疑病症的播客。这家伙就是个摇钱树。让他等15分钟，然后带他进来见我。简直不可思议。嗯哼，是的，那就是我。你觉得累吗？
You get hungry? Take some of this. You get hungry, huh? Yeah, that doesn't sound right. Are you finding yourself breathing a bunch? I'm like, into your nose and out through the mouth. Yeah, sit down. Fred, are you, you're not a hypochondriac.
你觉得饿吗？吃点这个。你觉得饿，是吧？是啊，那听起来不对劲。你发现自己呼吸很急促吗？我就像，吸入鼻子，通过嘴呼出。是啊，坐下。Fred，你是，你不是疑病症患者吧。
I don't think. I don't think I am. No. No, you don't strike me. What's anything wrong with you at all, Fred? Anything you'd like to change about yourself? Things that are bothering you? I think I'm a people pleaser.
我不觉得。我不觉得我是。不。不，你给我的印象不是。你身上有什么不对劲吗，Fred？有什么你想改变自己的地方吗？有什么困扰你的事情吗？我觉得我是一个讨好型人格。
I could, that would be a good change. You'd like to care less? Yeah. Show me one people that you've pleased. One that's happy. I would love to meet them. I would love to meet them. One that feels satisfied.
我可以，那会是一个很好的改变。你想少在乎一点吗？是啊。给我看一个你讨好过的人。一个快乐的人。我很想见见他们。我很想见见他们。一个感到满足的人。
Is that when people go, like I'm a people pleaser, I'm like, no, when are you gonna start? What are you talking about? Yeah, one that feels safe to vocalize that. I also hate it when people go, when people say this, people go, you know, believe me,
这就是当人们说，我是个讨好型人格，我就想，不，你什么时候开始的？你在说什么？是啊，一个敢于说出这一点的人。我也讨厌人们说，当人们说这个时，人们会说，你知道，相信我，
nobody's gonna be tougher on me than myself. And I always think, let me have a crack at it. Let me have a crack at it. Let me have a fucking crack at it. Let me try. Let me try. Don't do it. Don't do it.
没有人会比我自己对我更严厉。我总是想，让我来试试。让我来试试。让我他妈的来试试。让我试试。让我试试。别做。别做。
Nope, you're bad. We'll be right back. Fred, I have a really, really boring question. Oh, thank God. Who did you find funny when you were younger? Is there a pamphlet you use, Sean? Benny Hill. I thought Benny Hill was funny.
不，你很糟糕。我们马上回来。Fred，我有一个非常、非常无聊的问题。哦，谢天谢地。你年轻时觉得谁好笑？你有什么小册子吗，Sean？Benny Hill。我觉得Benny Hill很好笑。
Benny Hill, really? Yeah. Huh. When I was a kid, I'm saying, when I was a kid. Oh yeah, when you were like seven. But then... When you were a teenager, when you were like 1985.
Benny Hill，真的吗？是啊。嗯。我小时候，我是说，我小时候。哦，是啊，当你七岁的时候。但后来……当你十几岁的时候，当你1985年左右的时候。
When I was a teenager, I watched SNL. So it would be the Eddie Murphy years, where I was sort of a teenager. And then, but there were still reruns from like the Dan Aykroyd years and stuff. So it was like right in between. How about when you were like in your 20s in those years where you were like thinking,
当我十几岁的时候，我看SNL。所以那是Eddie Murphy的年代，我当时算是十几岁。然后，但仍然有Dan Aykroyd年代的重播之类的。所以就像是在两者之间。当你二十多岁的时候，那些你觉得，
maybe I want to do this. Who are the people who are working? Like for instance, I'll give you an example. When I remember in the 90s, when I was living in New York, and I saw Bob and David doing Mr. Show. And I thought, fuck, that's great. I wish I could do that. Really?
也许我想做这个的时候，怎么样？当时有哪些人在工作？比如，我给你举个例子。当我在90年代住在纽约时，我看到Bob和David在做《Mr. Show》。我想，操，那太棒了。我希望我能做到。真的吗？
I don't want to be like that. Like those guys. So were you all super starstruck when Cross came on Arrested Development? Who me? Yeah, or had you met him before? No, we had met before. I kind of knew him a little bit already.
我不想像那样。像那些家伙。所以当Cross出现在《发展受阻》时，你们都超级追星吗？谁，我？是啊，或者你们之前见过面？不，我们之前见过。我已经稍微认识他一点了。
But yeah, I mean, I was such a, he knew that. I was such a huge fan of his and Bob's. And yeah, of course, man. Like I was... Very cool. Yeah. Larry Sanders was like that for me. Yeah.
但是，是啊，我的意思是，我是如此的，他知道这一点。我是他和Bob的超级粉丝。而且，是啊，当然，伙计。就像我……太酷了。是啊。《拉里·桑德斯秀》对我来说也是那样。是啊。
When that show started, when I'd start seeing that, I go, what are they doing? What is that? What is this even called? Yeah. You know, it was just so great like that. That whole no winking kind of thing. Yeah.
当那个节目开始时，当我开始看到那个，我心想，他们在做什么？那是什么？这甚至叫什么？是啊。你知道，它就是那么棒。那种完全没有眨眼暗示的感觉。是啊。
Just like it was no one was asking for a laugh at all. And if they heard you laugh, they'd be offended. Like this is serious shit. I don't mind if somebody winks at me though. You know what I mean? I'm just saying like on a train. Sure. I don't mind like if somebody...
就像没有人要求你笑一样。如果他们听到你笑，他们会感到被冒犯。就像这是严肃的事情。我不介意有人对我眨眼。你懂我的意思吗？我只是说在火车上。当然。我不介意如果有人……
On a train. Yeah. Like if I want to... I'm going to do it right now. Wink at me, Fred. Fred's winking it. By the way, you can really put people off if you say something and then you just start...
在火车上。是啊。就像如果我想……我现在就要做。对我眨眼，Fred。Fred在眨眼。顺便说一句，如果你说了什么，然后你只是开始……
And then you wink a little bit. And then I'm just like... Just in the middle. Because I do... I will wink at people and my buddy Josh will go like, don't fucking wink at me, man. I wonder if winking died already. I wonder if it's about to disappear.
然后你眨了一下眼。然后我就像……就在中间。因为我做……我会对人眨眼，我的伙计Josh会说，别他妈对我眨眼，伙计。我不知道眨眼是不是已经过时了。我不知道它是不是快要消失了。
I go through phases of it. I'll end up... I'll wink for like a week or something like that. And then I'll stop for a while. But I'll just involuntarily do kind of what you're talking about, Will. Yeah. Sean, you were just practicing.
我会经历一些阶段。我会……我会眨眼大概一周左右之类的。然后我会停一段时间。但我会不由自主地做你说的那些，Will。是啊。Sean，你刚才在练习。
I was practicing because you know what... God, you're so stupid, Sean. You're trying to see if you can do it with both eyes? Sean was just practicing close really in my own head. I was like, do I do that? And I do do it. I do it to Scotty all the time, my husband's Scotty. And I'll do it in the most gross,
我在练习，因为你知道什么……天哪，你太蠢了，Sean。你是在试着看能不能两只眼睛一起做吗？Sean刚才只是在自己脑子里练习。我想，我做那个吗？我确实做。我一直对Scotty做，我丈夫Scotty。而且我会以最恶心、
disgusting, despicable way possible. He'll be like, God, you know what? If we get an argument, on the middle of the argument, I go, everything's going to be okay. And he fucking hates it. Oh yeah. So you do that to enrage it.
最卑鄙、最可鄙的方式做。他会说，天哪，你知道吗？如果我们吵架，在吵架中间，我说，一切都会好起来的。他他妈的讨厌这个。哦，是啊。所以你这样做是为了激怒他。
Most people don't wink to enrage people. Yeah, go ahead. I've been working out for on camera is the half wink, where the lids never actually touch. It's just a little bit of like a, it's just a little, it's like a little fissure that happens. Yeah, I know exactly what you mean.
大多数人眨眼不是为了激怒别人。是啊，继续。我一直在练习的是半眨眼，眼睑从来没有真正接触过。只是有一点点，就像一个，只是有一点点，就像一个小裂缝。是啊，我完全明白你的意思。
Both eyes are one eye. No, no, just the one. It's the cheesier cousin of a wink, actually, if you can get cheesier. And Jason, it's usually accompanied by like a mm, mm. Or just like a, mm, mm. You know what I mean? You've done not sarcastically, like without irony.
两只眼睛还是单眼？不，不，就一只。这是眨眼的廉价表亲，实际上，如果你能更廉价的话。而且Jason，它通常伴随着像嗯，嗯。或者只是像，嗯，嗯。你懂我的意思吗？你做的时候不是讽刺的，就像没有反讽。
I don't know how to do non-sarcastic humor. That's what I mean. I want to, that's what I don't mind if somebody winks. The real wink, I think. Like a real wink on it. If you're on a train and somebody gives you a real wink. Ew, what? Did you say wink?
我不知道怎么做非讽刺的幽默。这就是我的意思。我想，这就是我不介意有人眨眼的原因。真正的眨眼，我想。就像一个真正的眨眼。如果你在火车上，有人给你一个真正的眨眼。呃，什么？你说眨眼？
Does that happen? A real, no, in England, you get a real wink. And then here you get a real wink. Yeah. But if you, no, I'm saying, if you get a, like, if you're like on a bus, always on public transport. Sure.
会发生那种事吗？一个真正的，不，在英国，你会得到一个真正的眨眼。然后在这里你会得到一个真正的眨眼。是啊。但如果你，不，我是说，如果你得到一个，就像，如果你在公共汽车上，总是在公共交通工具上。当然。
You're just saying, or like, but if you're in a restaurant and you looked across, you were having dinner with somebody, you're having, Jason, you're having dinner with Amanda, and you're sitting there, and then you looked across, and then there was another couple, they were having dinner, and the guy just looked over at you and winked. Oh.
你只是说，或者像，但如果你在餐馆里，你抬头看，你和某人共进晚餐，你正在，Jason，你和Amanda共进晚餐，你坐在那里，然后你抬头看，然后有另一对夫妇，他们正在吃晚饭，那个家伙只是看着你，眨了眨眼。哦。
Would you, what would you? I would check my plate. Let's see what the fuck is this guy talking about. No, but have any of you actually ever winked at somebody to hit on them? The original purpose of the wink? No. I've never used it.
你会，你会怎么样？我会检查我的盘子。让我们看看这个家伙在说什么。不，但你们中有人真的为了搭讪而对人眨过眼吗？眨眼的最初目的？没有。我从来没用过。
No, that's so gross. No. Right, would that even work? And if so, what year did that work last in? I feel like winking went out right after the release of Rudd Stewart's Blondes Have More Fun. It was right after that, as soon as that record came out, then winking went out.
不，那太恶心了。不。对，那真的有用吗？如果是的话，那是哪一年最后一次奏效的？我觉得眨眼在Rudd Stewart的《Blondes Have More Fun》发行后就过时了。就在那之后，那张唱片一出来，眨眼就过时了。
A lot of people can't wink with both eyes, you know, there's only one eye that works for the wink. That's called blink, yeah, that's blinking. No, no, sorry, I mean, I mean, they can only wink with one eye. The other eye does not work for winking. I think it's made up. Fred, do you love working?
很多人不能两只眼睛一起眨，你知道，只有一只眼睛能眨。那叫眨眼，是啊，那是眨眼。不，不，抱歉，我是说，我是说，他们只能用一只眼睛眨眼。另一只眼睛不能眨。我觉得那是编出来的。Fred，你热爱工作吗？
Boy, that was smooth. Thanks, Sean. Thanks. Let's move on. Do you love working, because you work all the time, do you love it? Fred, are you a workaholic? I do, I'm a workaholic and I love working.
天哪，那太顺滑了。谢谢，Sean。谢谢。让我们继续。你热爱工作吗，因为你一直都在工作，你喜欢它吗？Fred，你是工作狂吗？我喜欢，我是工作狂，我热爱工作。
You do? I like my calendar to be filled. If there's empty dates, I'm like, okay, what can I figure out for that? Are you being serious? Yeah, I prefer to be working. When was the last time you took like a vacation? I can't remember.
你真的吗？我喜欢我的日程表被填满。如果有空档，我会想，好吧，我能为那个想出什么办法？你是认真的吗？是啊，我更喜欢工作。你上次休假是什么时候？我不记得了。
Ah, vacation, vacation. What just happened? What happened? Sit down, Sean, elevate your ankles, get them up over your arms. I literally thought somebody had hijacked our show. I'm like, what the fuck is going on? I was trying to do my work.
啊，度假，度假。刚才发生了什么？发生了什么？坐下，Sean，抬高你的脚踝，把它们抬到手臂上方。我真的以为有人劫持了我们的节目。我心想，他妈的发生了什么？我当时在试着做我的工作。
That was so weird. Sean, how long did the guy say the mushrooms were gonna last? The big, the big, I was trying to do my will, I know. It's supposed to be micro dosing, not macro dosing. I can't do impressions. I like to work all the time too, but I do really like my family,
那太奇怪了。Sean，那家伙说蘑菇会持续多久？大的，大的，我当时在试着做我的遗嘱，我知道。应该是微量给药，不是大量给药。我不会做模仿。我也喜欢一直工作，但我确实很喜欢我的家人，
and I do like to do zero as well. There's nothing in between. Yeah, same. I got problems. What about traveling, Jason? You mean for vacation? Yeah. I don't as well, the boring answer, I apologize,
而且我也喜欢什么都不做。两者之间没有中间地带。是啊，一样。我有问题。旅行怎么样，Jason？你是说度假？是啊。我也不，无聊的回答，我道歉，
is that my mother was a flight attendant when I was a kid growing up. So we flew everywhere. I've been all over the world, but at an age before I could appreciate the cultural value of it. So it was just, wait, so we're gonna fly away from my toys and my friends again,
是我母亲在我小时候是个空姐。所以我们到处飞。我去过世界各地，但在我能欣赏其文化价值的年龄之前。所以只是，等等，所以我们要再次飞离我的玩具和朋友，
and I got to sleep in some weird place. So I kind of have a bad taste in my mouth about travel and wanderlust and all that stuff. So I'm not the best person to ask about that. Yes you are. Yes you are. Yes you are. Don't ever let anyone say that to you, Jason.
而且我得睡在某个奇怪的地方。所以我对旅行和漫游癖之类的东西有点反感。所以我不是问这个的最佳人选。你是。你是。你是。别让任何人那样对你说，Jason。
You're the best person to ask. Do you like the traveling, Will? I do, I certainly. Sean. I don't, I do not love it, no. Sean travels, I feel like the last few trips, I had to make him travel. Yeah, I have to, I'm going to a trip
你是问这个的最佳人选。你喜欢旅行吗，Will？我喜欢，我当然。Sean。我不，我不喜欢，不。Sean旅行，我觉得最后几次旅行，我不得不让他旅行。是啊，我要去旅行，
to see Will tomorrow actually, and it's an actual trip. Well, I'm going at the end of next week, Sean. You've been threatening to be there at the same time I'm gonna be there, are you going to? I can't, what do you mean you can't? They're both coming to see me in the next week. Are they really? Sean and Scotty are coming out tomorrow,
明天去见Will，实际上，这是一次真正的旅行。好吧，我下周末去，Sean。你一直威胁说要在我也在那儿的时候去，你要去吗？我不能，你什么意思你不能？他们下周都要来看我。他们真的吗？Sean和Scotty明天出来，
and then Jason and the kids and Amanda are coming next week. Sean, why are you not gonna be there when I'm there? I have to go back for work to LA, so I can't stick around. Because of work, you see? Now Freddie, so like you go to New York, you go to London for a week, which right now is a pain in the ass
然后Jason和孩子们还有Amanda下周来。Sean，为什么我在那儿的时候你不在？我得回洛杉矶工作，所以我不能待着。因为工作，你明白吗？现在Freddie，所以你去了纽约，你去伦敦待了一周，这现在很麻烦，
because I'm sure there are a lot of protocols and shit you have to go through before you start work, I imagine. Yeah, I mean. It looks like you're still at the airport. Are you still like in a room at an airport? No, I'm at my hotel. Okay.
因为我肯定在你开始工作之前有很多协议和狗屁事要处理，我想。是啊，我的意思是。看起来你还在机场。你还在机场的房间里吗？不，我在酒店。好的。
I swear to God, I'm not at the airport. Oh my God. Why would I lie? I'm at a hotel. I believe you. In quarantine, I'm not allowed to leave. They're still in quarantine here. You're not allowed to leave the hotel for a little while?
我发誓，我不在机场。天哪。我为什么要撒谎？我在酒店。我相信你。在隔离中，我不被允许离开。他们在这里还在隔离。你不被允许离开酒店一段时间？
I'm not allowed to leave the hotel. For how long? Five days. Wow, my God. So what, do you literally have to stay in the hotel room for five days? Yep. Tell us what you've been doing.
我不被允许离开酒店。多久？五天。哇，天哪。所以，你真的必须在酒店房间里待五天吗？是的。告诉我们你一直在做什么。
You can't even go outside. I'm trying to memorize my lines. Huh, you need five days to memorize a week of lines? I, it takes me a little extra work. You're not good at that, huh? I think I'm not. I think I'm okay. I'm okay if I keep practicing it,
你甚至不能去外面。我正在试着背我的台词。哈，你需要五天来背一周的台词？我，这需要我额外的工作。你不擅长那个，是吧？我觉得我不擅长。我觉得我还行。如果我一直练习，我还可以，
but I am not like, I don't pick it up that easy. So you would always use the cards on SNL. You'd never get off book at all? No, we're not supposed to. Not supposed to? You're supposed to look right at the cards so that you look like you're looking at the other person. Right, but what if you learn your lines
但我不是那种，我记不住那么容易。所以你在SNL总是用卡片。你从来不脱稿吗？不，我们不应该。不应该？你应该直接看卡片，这样看起来就像你在看对方。对，但如果你背下了台词，
and you can look at the person? It changes too often. Yeah. It changes too often. From dress rehearsal to air, without fail, everything just gets changed. Right. Wow.
你可以看对方？它变动太频繁了。是啊。它变动太频繁了。从彩排到播出，毫无例外，一切都会变。对。哇。
Jason, you know less than Tracy from Wisconsin. No, I'm just, I am, I'm just thinking back to the, when I was there. How many times you've hosted SNL and you, and how many times have we gone to SNL together? You're right. It does, it does change quite a bit. Yeah, it changes and then...
Jason，你知道的比威斯康星州的Tracy还少。不，我只是，我只是回想起我在那儿的时候。你主持过多少次SNL，我们一起去过多少次SNL？你是对的。它确实，它确实变动很大。是啊，它变了，然后……
What do you want to do? You want to put Wally? You want to put Wally out of work? You want Wally? Yeah, totally, come on. Oh, Wally's kids don't need braces. Okay, that's cool. Well, Wally doesn't need to pay his mortgage.
你想做什么？你想让Wally失业吗？你想要Wally？是啊，完全可以，得了吧。哦，Wally的孩子不需要牙套。好吧，那很酷。好吧，Wally不需要付房贷。
Where'd he go? He didn't need a house. Why would Wally need a house? This kid's only reigning. It's only rain, Jason. Does rain bother, why would rain bother? I mean, he's a living organism on the planet. Rain should give him nourishment.
他去哪儿了？他不需要房子。为什么Wally需要房子？这孩子只是在下雨。只是下雨，Jason。雨会困扰，为什么雨会困扰？我的意思是，他是地球上的一个活生物。雨应该给他营养。
That place is such a special spot. My God, Wally. Yeah, it really is. I just love it. Yes, it is. I love it so much. I do text with Wally sometimes, by the way. You do?
那个地方真是个特别的地方。天哪，Wally。是啊，确实是。我只是喜欢它。是的，确实是。我太喜欢它了。我有时确实会给Wally发短信，顺便说一句。你发吗？
Yeah. I thought you made that name up. That's a real person. No. No, no, he's the guy. Oh, okay. He's got like a whole system that like, now the people who worked for him do Seth's show or, you know.
是啊。我以为你编造了那个名字。那是真人。不。不，不，他是那个人。哦，好吧。他有一整套系统，现在为他工作的人做Seth的节目，或者，你知道。
Fred, did we talk about why are you in London? What is the project you're working on there? I'm working on a show that Matt Berry does, the British- Oh, that's right. You said that, sorry. And it's a show called Toast of London. Okay, Toast of London.
Fred，我们谈过你为什么在伦敦吗？你在那里做什么项目？我正在做一个Matt Berry做的节目，那个英国的——哦，对了。你说了，抱歉。那是一个叫《伦敦吐司》的节目。好的，《伦敦吐司》。
Oh, so they're doing another season of it? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, I didn't know that. That's great. It's so funny. It's so funny. That's great. Who else are you?
哦，所以他们正在做另一季？是啊，是啊，是啊。哦，我不知道。那太棒了。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。那太棒了。还有谁？
I've just been reading my lines. Who else is in it? I'm not sure. I think Rashida's doing something. I was actually gonna say, who else are you gonna see when you're there? Like once they break you out. Oh, I don't know yet.
我一直在读我的台词。还有谁在里面？我不确定。我觉得Rashida在做点什么。我其实正想说，当你到那儿时，你还会见到谁？一旦他们让你出来。哦，我还不知道。
I don't know yet, but I really love it here, for real. I really believe it. Yeah, same, same, same, same, same. So you're in the room for five days. So it's all room service and learning your lines. And is there some TV watching or is there some reading? You know, I tried and I watched a little bit of TV and it just made me sleepy.
我还不知道，但我真的很喜欢这里，真的。我是真心的。是啊，我也是，我也是，我也是，我也是，我也是。所以你要在房间里待五天。所以就是一直叫客房服务，然后背台词。那会看电视或者看书吗？你知道，我试过，也看了一会儿电视，但那只会让我犯困。
It was great, but it was a lot of reality TV. So then what are you doing? Are you a reader? Do you read books? Are you making music? That's such a good question. Why do I feel like I've been communicating a lot. I feel like I've been emailing and texting.
那感觉很棒，但全是真人秀。那你都在做什么？你是个爱读书的人吗？你会看书吗？你在做音乐吗？这问题问得真好。为什么我觉得我一直在跟人交流。我觉得我一直在发邮件和短信。
So a lot of that kind of stuff. This was like my big event for today. No joke. My whole day was like, this is my thing. I'm gonna build a day around that. I did bring my guitar. I brought my guitar. Okay, great.
所以大部分时间都在做这些事。这算是我今天的大事了。没开玩笑。我的一整天就是这样，这就是我的重点。我要围绕这个来安排我的一天。我确实带了吉他。我带了吉他。好的，太棒了。
You want to play us a little something working on anything? I have this like little travel guitar that I have. And then I just, I took it out of the room because I was like, is there anything worse than seeing that someone's got like a guitar in the room? Yeah, it's always in the background of fun. It's always in the background. But I have this little travel guitar that I brought for me.
你想给我们弹点什么吗？在创作什么吗？我有个小型的旅行吉他。然后我把它从房间里拿出来了，因为我在想，还有什么比看到别人在房间里放把吉他更糟糕的事吗？是啊，它总是在背景里显得很有趣。它总是在背景里。但我带了这个小旅行吉他，是给我自己用的。
And it looks like this, but then there's like no head to it. Yeah. So it's always in tune. There it is. So we've got a great theme song for smart less. But if we were to have a second best theme tune for smart less, it probably would go like. You probably want, you know, your audience,
它看起来是这样的，但琴头没了。对。所以它总是调好音的。就是这样。我们已经有了一首很棒的《SmartLess》主题曲。但如果我们还要有第二好的《SmartLess》主题曲，它大概会是这样的。你可能想要，你知道，你的听众，
you want them on their feet. Yeah. You want them jumping up on their feet. You want them clapping their hands. Energy. So it's very sort of, you just want the rhythm. Yeah. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, get up.
你想要他们站起来。对。你想要他们跳起来。你想要他们拍手。要有活力。所以这很像，你只需要节奏。对。嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，站起来。
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, get up. Get up. Welcome listener. Get up. Again, again, and again. I say get up. Get up. Again, and again, and again.
嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，站起来。站起来。欢迎听众。站起来。再一次，再一次，再一次。我说站起来。站起来。再一次，再一次，再一次。
Jump up and down. And then that's it. That's great. I think you just, yeah. No melody, just a little. I think it's great. Where it's just like your ears are bleeding and you're like, God, I just, no matter what they're talking
跳上跳下。然后就这样。太棒了。我觉得你刚才，对。没有旋律，就一点点。我觉得很棒。那种让你的耳朵流血，然后你会觉得，天哪，我只是，不管他们在聊什么，
about on this podcast is going to be better than this. And yeah. What music are you listening to right now, Freddie? What are you listening to? There's a band I really love called Def Rain. Man, they're terrible. D-E-F. It's so funny you brought them up.
在这个播客里聊的都比这个好。是啊。你现在在听什么音乐，弗雷迪？你在听什么？有个乐队我真的很喜欢，叫Def Rain。天哪，他们太烂了。D-E-F。你提到他们真好笑。
Oh, go to hell. You know what? Yeah, no, no, no. Let's hear it. Okay. Let's hear it. Def Rain? I've never heard them.
哦，见鬼去吧。你知道吗？是啊，不，不，不。让我们听听看。好的。让我们听听。Def Rain？我从没听说过他们。
D-E-F-R-A-I-N, like Rain, like what Will was talking about before. Def Rain and what kind of music do they make? They're a duo from Dallas and it's like spooky, I'd say kind of electronic but it's very spooky. That's cool. And I love it.
D-E-F-R-A-I-N，像雨（Rain）一样，就像威尔之前说的。Def Rain，他们做什么样的音乐？他们是来自达拉斯的二人组，我觉得有点诡异，算是电子乐，但非常诡异。那很酷。我很喜欢。
I'm going to look them up. Def Rain. Where do you, Fred, where do you fall on, where do you fall on Duran Duran? I'm a big Duran Duran guy. You sure are, Will. I think they were really revolutionary in bringing new romantic music to MTV, to the masses.
我要去搜搜他们。Def Rain。弗雷德，你觉得杜兰杜兰（Duran Duran）怎么样？我是杜兰杜兰的铁粉。你当然是，威尔。我觉得他们在把新浪漫主义音乐带给MTV，带给大众方面，真的具有革命性。
There we go. Like no other, I don't think any other band succeeded like they did. They were a real new romantic band. I think John Taylor is a great bass player. I like that most of their, the band members are like sort of intact. They have like most of the guys.
就是这样。像他们一样成功的乐队，我想不出还有谁。他们是真正的新浪漫主义乐队。我觉得约翰·泰勒是个很棒的贝斯手。我喜欢他们大多数乐队成员都还在。他们大部分人都在。
And I think that like their early days of synths, like they are the ones who like brought it to top 10. Oh God. I just want to go sailing with Simon LeBon. Who's kidding? Who's kidding? It can happen. Make that happen for sure.
而且我觉得他们早期的合成器音乐，他们是把这种音乐带进前十名的人。天哪。我真想和西蒙·勒·邦一起去航海。谁在开玩笑？谁在开玩笑？这可能会发生的。一定要让它发生。
So Freddie, so now you're there doing this show with Matt Barry. You've done, you kind of, it kind of want to get back to what Jason was saying. Like you did Fortlandia, you killed it. Like what, what for you would be the thing that you feel like you haven't done yet in comedy anyway, that you would, that would be like,
所以弗雷迪，现在你在和马特·贝里做这个节目。你已经做了，你有点，我想回到杰森刚才说的话题。你做了《波特兰迪亚》，你表现得太棒了。对你来说，在喜剧方面，还有什么事是你觉得还没做过的，
oh, that's something I really want to go and tackle? I would say doing something in a foreign language, but really doing something in a foreign language. Like really doing it. Like in, in Farsi, something in Farsi. Wow. Where it's not like a, where it's like not, you know, it's not like a, the joke of it isn't
哦，那是你真的很想去挑战的？我想说用外语做点什么，但真的是用外语做点什么。就像真的去做。比如用波斯语，用波斯语做点什么。哇。不是那种，不是那种，你知道，笑点不是
that I'm speaking Farsi. Right, no, no, no, no. It's like a, something that takes place. And why do you want to do that? Because of the challenge of it? Yeah. Like something that takes place in Tehran and, because yeah, because of the challenge of it.
因为我在说波斯语。对，不，不，不。就像是，发生在某个地方的事情。你为什么想做那个？是因为挑战性吗？对。就像发生在德黑兰的事情，因为，对，因为它的挑战性。
Yeah. Well, assuming that's serious. Yeah, that's serious. Okay. Aside from that though, just generally in, with your career, with the acting, with the writing, with the producing, so are you, is your sort of,
是啊。好吧，假设那是认真的。对，那是认真的。不过除此之外，就你的职业生涯而言，演戏、写作、制作，所以你，你的那种，
are you looking to escalate things? Like is your, is your, is your internal clock going, okay, what, what could be net, or are you happy to just kind of just live, keep things as is. I want to be fed. I want to be housed. I want to be happy.
你在寻求提升吗？你的，你的，你的内心时钟在说，好吧，接下来能做什么，还是你满足于就这样生活，保持现状？我想有饭吃。我想有房住。我想快乐。
I just want to cruise along. Or, or are you, are you the type of person that's looking to, this could lead to, this could lead to that. And the, to- How strong is your ambition? It's a combo of the two in that, none of my aspirations as I was going along, were ever that grand anyway.
我只想顺其自然。或者，或者你是那种寻求，这可能会导致这个，这可能会导致那个的人。而且，你的野心有多强？这是两者的结合，因为我一路走来，我的抱负从来没有那么宏大。
It was, Port Landy was always like, this is, this is fine. It doesn't have to be on a huge network. Right. So, but it still was, but it still was very satisfying. So it's like a combo of the two of like, I like this pace. This is feeling really, I'm, you know, every day, every day seems to be something exciting.
一直以来，《波特兰迪亚》就是，这，这很好。它不需要在大型电视网播出。对。所以，但它依然，但它依然非常令人满足。所以这就像是两者的结合，我喜欢这个节奏。这感觉真的，我，你知道，每一天，每一天似乎都有令人兴奋的事情。
I'm in London or, you know, Italy or something. And then, and then I do, I just, I honestly do like the idea of something completely foreign to me. Something like in another language, something, something that like I haven't done before. So like a mix. Let me ask you a different way.
我在伦敦，或者，你知道，意大利什么的。然后，然后我确实，我真心喜欢那种对我来说完全陌生的想法。比如用另一种语言做点什么，做点什么，做点我以前没做过的事情。所以就像是一种混合。让我换个方式问你。
What if a map, if you were part of something that became uncontrollably massive and you couldn't walk down the street, but you had, You don't mean like elephantitis. Yeah. You mean a project, you mean a project. Yeah.
如果，如果你参与的东西变得无法控制地巨大，你走在街上都没法走，但你有了，你不是指象皮病吧。对，你是说一个项目，你是说一个项目。对。
I'm just saying, well, how would you, if you had a massive amount of what, what people would call success, how, what, what, what, would that be a happy thing? Would, or would that make you a complete, would you be like, God damn it, I can't go to the market anymore? No, I'd be like, oh, how nice that things turned out this way.
我只是说，好吧，如果你拥有了人们所说的巨大成功，那，那，那，那会是一件快乐的事吗？或者那会让你彻底，你会不会觉得，该死，我再也不能去市场了？不，我会觉得，哦，事情变成这样真好。
Who knew? Uh-huh. Who knew? I sometimes think about that with Bob Odenkirk, with the fact that Better Call Saul was so huge, it had nothing to do with what his plan was, you know? He was, you know, doing sketch, comedy and all this other stuff.
谁知道呢？嗯哼。谁知道呢？我有时会想到鲍勃·奥登科克，想到《风骚律师》那么火，这和他原本的计划毫无关系，你知道吗？他，你知道，在做小品，喜剧和所有其他东西。
And like, it seemed, I liked that, that sort of surprise. Right. And do you think you'd be able to adapt to that? Yeah, sure. Yeah. Are you kidding? Fred can't wait to not be able to go to the market.
而且，我喜欢那种，那种惊喜。对。你觉得你能适应吗？对，当然。是啊。你在开玩笑吗？弗雷德等不及要变得不能去市场了。
He's like, yeah, he's like. I hate markets. He hates fucking Fred. I just figured it out. I figured out, we have to do a comedy and we both have to do it in Germany where we play guards, Stasi border guards. It's all in subtitles.
他就像，是啊，他就像。我讨厌市场。他讨厌该死的弗雷德。我刚想到了。我想到了，我们必须做一个喜剧，我们俩都得在德国演，演守卫，斯塔西边境守卫。全都有字幕。
Yes. It's like checkpoint. And it's called Checkpoint Charlies. Oh yeah. Yeah. And we're just two border guards and we live in East Berlin. Maybe we could do it where like,
对。就像检查站。名字叫《查理检查站》。哦，对。对。我们就是两个边境守卫，住在东柏林。也许我们可以演成，
we both find out that we're supposed to spy on each other. Yes. You're like, oh, you're my guy? Oh, I'm your guy. Oh, I got to look in your fridge. Send me some shots of your fridge. That's actually really funny. That's really good, right?
我们俩都发现对方被派来监视自己。对。你就像，哦，你是派来监视我的人？哦，我是派来监视你的人。哦，我得看看你的冰箱。给我发几张你冰箱的照片。那真的很有趣。那真的很好，对吧？
I mean, if you're listening out there, feel free to call either our reps and Fred and I will take a meeting. And then the scene would be like, where are you going? I don't know, where are you going? I don't know. Yeah.
我是说，如果你在听的话，随时可以联系我们的经纪人，弗雷德和我一定会去开会。然后场景会是这样的，你要去哪？我不知道，你要去哪？我不知道。对。
Apparently you seem to know where I'm going. It seems to be so important to you. What do you want to map? What's on your sandwich? You don't want to, you have plenty of mail at home. I'm surprised you didn't use any. There are a camera over the fridge, there's a camera right here, camera down.
显然你好像知道我要去哪。这对你来说似乎很重要。你要什么，马特？你的三明治里有什么？你不想，你家里有很多邮件。我很惊讶你没用过。冰箱上方有个摄像头，这里有个摄像头，下面有个摄像头。
A camera down? The one take one camera, yeah. By the way, for a police force, that's pretty cool, Stasi. How come we don't have that? It's not as good as checkpoint chases. We have a domestic intelligence network. You know what I mean?
下面有个摄像头？一镜到底，一个摄像头，对。顺便说一句，对于警察部队来说，那挺酷的，斯塔西。为什么我们没有那个？那不如《查理检查站》好。我们有国内情报网络。你知道我的意思吗？
I mean, we get kind of like robbed of all that kind of shit over here, you know what I mean? We don't have like cool, like, like domestic intelligence services that are like watching us and stuff, you know what I mean? No. Not one of them. No.
我是说，我们在这边被剥夺了所有那种破事，你知道我的意思吗？我们没有那种很酷的，像，像国内情报机构在监视我们之类的，你知道我的意思吗？没有。一个都没有。没有。
I know. Because we talked about the American experience, but we've been like... Give it to us. Like let us have it. So anyway, Freddie, fuck, so great to have you on the show, man. No!
我知道。因为我们谈论过美国经历，但我们一直被……给我们吧。让我们也体验一下。总之，弗雷迪，该死，你能来节目真是太好了，伙计。不！
Yeah. Yeah. Come on in then. Let's talk. Let's read just the bits. Let's talk. When's your birthday? You got any pets?
是啊。是啊。进来吧。我们聊聊。我们读读那些片段。我们聊聊。你生日是什么时候？你有宠物吗？
No pets. No pets. When's your birthday? How about favorite colors? Sean, Sean, you didn't get to the favorite color question. I did see, there's a beautiful color I saw. Maybe a month ago. Where were you?
没有宠物。没有宠物。你生日是什么时候？最喜欢的颜色是什么？肖恩，肖恩，你没问最喜欢的颜色那个问题。我确实看到过，我一个月前看到过一种美丽的颜色。你在哪？
Where were you? Jesus Christ. You guys should check it out. Fred, I want to say something. I don't know when I'm ever going to see you again, hopefully soon when you're back in LA or something. Are you dying, Sean? Holy shit.
你在哪？天哪。你们应该去看看。弗雷德，我想说点什么。我不知道我什么时候还能再见到你，希望很快，当你回到洛杉矶或者什么地方的时候。你要死了吗，肖恩？该死。
Yeah, what's going on? I always wanted to say this, that you are truly, truly one of the funniest people and I just think you are so incredibly talented. Good, Sean. Oh, well, it's mutual, Sean. That's really, really nice. You are the tip top, Fred.
是啊，怎么了？我一直想说，你真的是，真的是最有趣的人之一，我觉得你非常有才华。很好，肖恩。哦，好吧，彼此彼此，肖恩。那真的，真的很好。你是最棒的，弗雷德。
You really are, Fred. You guys are. Fred used to do this bit at 8H and SNL, and he'd go, he'd walk around, but then he was like an intern and he'd go, I'm the only one that's normal around here. He used to fucking make me laugh so hard. Norma.
你真的是，弗雷德。你们都是。弗雷德以前在《周六夜现场》做过这个段子，他会走来走去，但他当时演的是个实习生，他会说，我是这里唯一正常的人。他以前总是能把我逗得大笑。诺玛。
Freddy, you're the funny. I love you guys. I love you. I love your show a lot. You're the comedian's comedian. You're the comedian's comedian. You really are. Everybody loves you and you're the, for good reason.
弗雷迪，你才是那个有趣的。我爱你们。我非常喜欢你们的节目。你是喜剧演员中的喜剧演员。你是喜剧演员中的喜剧演员。你真的是。每个人都爱你，而且是有充分理由的。
You're the fucking funniest and you're such a lovely guy. And thank you for saying yes. Yeah. And I can't wait to see you again soon, hopefully. And all the best. Thanks, you guys. And hope you have a good visit with each other. Yeah, thank you.
你是最该死的有趣，而且你是个如此可爱的人。谢谢你答应来。是啊。我迫不及待想很快再见到你，希望如此。祝一切顺利。谢谢你们。希望你们玩得开心。是啊，谢谢。
Thank you, pal. Have fun, Freddy. We love you, Freddy. We love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. What a kind, funny, talented man.
谢谢，伙计。玩得开心，弗雷迪。我们爱你，弗雷迪。我们爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。多么善良、有趣、有才华的人。
He really is. I mean, I meant what I said. Nice going, Will. Nice going. He's one of those, I love... He was on my list, too, to be on the show. He's always got a really great bit, too. You can have not seen him for three years,
他真的是。我是说，我是认真的。干得好，威尔。干得好。他是那种，我喜欢……他也在我的节目嘉宾名单上。他总是有很棒的段子。你可以三年没见过他，
and he'll come up and I'll go, hey, can I ask you something really like- I just like, no time has passed. Yeah, and he's always got a bit in, but he's such a sweetheart of a guy. Yeah, he is. Fred did this thing when we were doing that rocker thing, he walked up one day, they had a bunch of bottles of water,
他走过来，我会说，嘿，我能问你个事吗，真的像……就像时间没流逝一样。是啊，他总是有段子，但他是个甜心。是啊，他是。弗雷德在我们做那个摇滚节目时做过一件事，有一天他走过来，他们有一堆瓶装水，
and he just grabs a bottle of water and he goes, nice budget. And then he walks away. But he always, and he's got, you know, when he was on SNL, he did, I don't know, 30 different characters that he would bring on to- I loved when he did Prince.
他抓起一瓶水说，不错的预算。然后他就走开了。但他总是，而且他有，你知道，当他在《周六夜现场》时，他演了，我不知道，30个不同的角色，他会带到……我喜欢他演王子（Prince）。
He would always, he would always whisper him to me. Prince, I do love Nicholas Fein, that political, God, that thing made me- It's stuff that he would do with Kristen Wiig all the time too. It's so clear that they had just this great, great, this chemical reaction together, you know, that would just- He's going down in history as one of the greats
他总是，他总是对我耳语。王子，我确实喜欢尼古拉斯·费恩，那个政治人物，天哪，那东西让我……他和克里斯汀·韦格一直做的那些东西也是。很明显，他们之间有这种很棒的，很棒的化学反应，你知道，那会……他将作为《周六夜现场》最伟大的人之一载入史册。
from Saturday Night Live. For sure, I agree. All of the decades. Yeah. He's one of the greats. He did a sketch about a guy who's got a one-man show that is one of the most cringe-worthy
当然，我同意。所有年代的。是啊。他是最伟大的人之一。他演过一个小品，关于一个做单人秀的家伙，那是让人最尴尬
and hilarious sketches. Oh my God, immediately look up Fred Armisen, one-man show. It's one of the funniest things you'll ever watch. For me, it is. It absolutely destroys me. That's why I was asking like, do you miss being in that weekly lab?
也是最搞笑的小品之一。天哪，立刻去搜弗雷德·阿米森的单人秀。这是你这辈子看过的最有趣的东西之一。对我来说是。它绝对让我笑翻了。这就是为什么我问，你怀念那种每周的实验室吗？
I feel like- You know why though? Why don't we, I'm mad we don't get to see that every single week. I know, that's how I feel. Well, that's kind of what I was saying though, but I don't think he misses it because he does it all day.
我觉得……你知道为什么吗？为什么我们，我很生气我们不能每周都看到那个。我知道，我也是这么觉得的。好吧，那正是我刚才说的，但我认为他不怀念，因为他整天都在做。
So he does it with everybody he needs to meet. I guess I was saying, I miss it, yeah. I miss seeing what comes out of his head each week. Yeah, yeah. Of course, because it's brilliant. I remember him one time texting Amy saying, hey, I can't make this stand-up. I'm supposed to do a stand-up gig in Dallas
所以他和他需要见到的每个人都在做。我想我是在说，我怀念它，是啊。我怀念看到他每周脑子里蹦出什么东西。是啊，是啊。当然，因为那太天才了。我记得有一次他给艾米发短信说，嘿，我没法参加这个脱口秀了。我下周要在达拉斯
next week, or Austin, I can't make it. Here's the thing, and he sent all the details, including the travel times, the person to meet, here are when the shows are, and then he writes, thanks so much. Super detailed flight numbers, everything. I can't make it. Can you do it for me?
或者奥斯汀有个脱口秀演出，我没法去了。事情是这样的，他发了所有细节，包括旅行时间，要见的人，演出时间，然后他写道，非常感谢。超级详细的航班号，什么都有。我没法去了。你能帮我做吗？
Thank you. Fuck, hilarious. That, he is so funny. Oh my God, I just got a text from him. Oh my God, guys, I just got a real-life text from Fred. You did? Yeah. Oh, now I'm floating.
谢谢。该死，太搞笑了。那，他太有趣了。天哪，我刚收到他的一条短信。天哪，伙计们，我刚收到弗雷德发来的真实短信。你收到了？是啊。哦，我现在飘飘然了。
Oh my God, and that, you know what? You got a text from him, you know why that is? Because that's a bye-bye product. And the show looks good, guys. Bye. Bye. Yee. Yee.
天哪，你知道吗？你收到了他的短信，你知道为什么吗？因为那是副产品。节目看起来不错，伙计们。再见。再见。耶。耶。
Smart. Plus. Smart. Plus. Smart. Plus. Smart. Plus.
Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally hand-crafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbicoe. The next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app. Smart. Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴比科手工制作，100%有机。下一集将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Wondry应用中的Wondry Plus收听。Smart。Less。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。